Why is he just lying?
H how how is he pretending that when me Queman uh Chud and a
bunch of other people, sorry, not me. I should say Riyle because
it was my VOD. But when when Riyle posts a video of me, Teeone,
Tees in the YouTube comments when Chud posts a video, Teone,
Tees in the YouTube comments. When Quimman posts a video, Teone
Tech's in the YouTube comments. How in the world is he saying
he doesn't watch other streamers when he sits there name searching
for any criticism so he can go and talk or like pretend it doesn't
bother him in the comments? This is so bizarre. This is so bizarre.
All right, this techn video um you'll just see the I don't even
know what it's about. It just says the title is guys streamers
disgust me and then it's like him out here outside this video.
Okay, this is like his diddy apology video right here. I the
energy I was just like
yes. Oh, this is this is like you're a woman and you want to
read a book midday
with like a cup of tea. That's like this is the chair that you
get. Yeah. Let's see. Let's see how he uses it. I'm almost positive
he did not pick this chair. I I know this is like crazy. I just
don't believe he actually picked this chair or sets any of the
stuff up. I don't see it. Don't believe it. Don't. No, I don't
think so. I doubt it. Very strongly. Yeah, that's like a girlfriend's
chair was like, "Oh, it'd be so cool to get a chair out here
in this exact spot." Yeah. I don't think any man has ever picked
a wicker
what is it called? Wicker bath wicker egg chair. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if you call it a whisker b a w a wicker.
A wicker basket chair. But anyway, I know it's supposed to be
my day off. Try to take a day off uh once every six days or so.
And the sound quality is probably pretty the lawn mower guy in
the background that that literally just started. By the way,
I I could end the recording and just say, "Ah, I'll wait till
he's done." But I already know these. Who does this remind you
of? Who does this remind you of instantly because of the noise
in the background and all the birds?
Wait, are you going to say Warren Smith? Did Warren Smith do
this? Yeah. He literally went outside in the worst like audio
conditions to do a video
with all the wind. Also,
like he just rambles about this. You could just literally not
You could just hit stop recording and hit record. Yeah, you could.
The the lawn mower just started.
Okay, stop and wait till it's done to record the video or go
inside. But no, title is streamers disgust me still. Okay. All
right. videos that I made don't really matter anyways. I don't
really think anybody cares.
Yeah, there's
little AC unit in the background going there. I got the sprinkler
over there. No, Mango. He's inside. He's been a very good boy.
Sophia's inside as well. Jenna's Anna, they're probably asleep
because uh Hold on. Is this an Asmin Gold video right here? Why
I live a simple life? It is just totally Asmin. Asmin coded.
Okay.
has been coded for sure. Okay. I actually think I might have
been uh No, I think it was you. It was you or Queman. Somebody
brought up the It was you. You brought up that the dude the Jubilee
person. Yeah. The Jubilee person and that person sitting more
masculine than him. Maybe that was I don't remember. It's not
important. But yeah, I I did think I just thought about him person
sitting like that and how it actually doesn't look very
It made me think of the Jubilee. Yeah,
I
I just see it as the as I I this is exactly what I thought was
I saw like the gold like outside videos that he does sometimes
to be like guys I do leave my house once in a while. I do. I
do occasionally.
Yeah. You know, my roommates don't wake up till the crack of
noon. Actually, Jenna wakes up at 3:00 a.m. So, I guess he's
probably up. But, uh yeah, I just kind of wanted to talk about
some thoughts that I've been having.
And uh I I would like to preface this saying like I'm in a very
good mental space right now. I'm very good mentally. I'm honestly
pretty happy, but just kind of
with the bigger I get, the more successful I get. And and I want
to make it very clear.
I'm I'm not successful
like the normal successful.
I'm not successful. I just find it very weird that like I've
never once thought about starting a stream and going like, "Hello,
hello, hello."
Just so you guys know, I feel very mentally stable today. I feel
very mentally healthy. I My mental health off the charts right
now. Okay. I've never once thought to do that. I feel like, isn't
that the exact thing that like when somebody is feeling really
insecure about something, they'll drop a detail that like you
don't need to know, don't care about, didn't weren't thinking
about, and it like puts you on to exactly what their problems
are. I don't know. That's how that when I hear like that, I'm
just like, "Okay, hey man, how are you? I'm really mentally well
right now." Oh, somebody
somebody comes up to you, they're like, "Listen, I need to talk
to you about something. It's going to sound a little off. I just
want you to know I took my medication."
And then from that point on, you're like, "Okay, this is not
going to be good, and I should know where all the exits are."
Looking around because I worked with the machine.
I'm successful because I worked in spite of the machine. I did
everything wrong as a content creator.
I legit This guy's turned into This guy is like um Okay. And
it's weird because I I've never watched this content creator
like ever, okay? Like not even really more than like 10 seconds.
The most I've ever seen as a content creator in one sitting is
in a movie. So
I feel like Techone is somehow going to become like weird pseudo
political right-wing streamer Russell Brand. I I feel like I'm
getting like Russell Brand energy from this where he like has
to talk about how everything works against him and how like he's
walked a totally different path and he can tell you about his
totally different path. There's like something Russell Brandcoded
going on here including the thing. So yes, it's like all there.
It's all within him. I I
just feel I it's so weird that he's doing this that he's going
and like talk about guys I I win in spite of the system. I work
outside of the system. I am very special. I am very very special
guys.
I don't Yeah. I don't know. I don't know why. I just That's who
I'm seeing. I'm seeing Russell Brand fully. And I and I still
am here today
breaking a million subscribers,
averaging sometimes well over 10 to 12,000 viewers on multiple
different streaming uh sites. And I'm not saying this because
I'm narcissistic, even though I am. I'm saying this because
I was in my bed just thinking I I had mango snoring on me and
I was just thinking about how difficult these past 6 and 1/2
years were and I get these messages of, man, I can't believe
you're you're willing to say this on stream. I can't believe
you're willing to say the quiet part out loud. I can't believe
you're willing to stick up for this person. I can't believe,
dude. It was so inspiring when you called Froggen fat. I was
so inspired by you. The way you called Froggen fat on Twitter,
that was so impressive to me. I That took real strength. Not
many people would be strong enough to call Froggen fat. And I
just wanted to let you know special. This is really special.
You stick to your values. I can't believe, you know, you're you're
fighting against, you know, the streamer clicks this, that, and
the other. And God, I sound like I'm really sucking my own right
now.
as a streamer. And what I mean by I guys, it is not narcissism
if you point out that you're actually doing it. Okay, if you
jerk yourself off on stream and say you're jerking yourself off,
you're not jerking yourself off. Them's the rules. I didn't make
it the wrong way is is because this is how you
And I don't mean in the short term. Anything can succeed in the
short term, but in the long term, I've had 6 and 1/2 years of
always being successful.
And for other streamers, this is how it goes. If you're an attractive
woman, congratulations. You've succeeded.
You have a career. You will. You can probably make tens of thousands
of dollars if you are a conventionally attractive woman. It's
like so lazy. It's just so
It's so lazy. It is cuz you know that's not true. You have to
literally be conventionally attractive and slightly mentally
ill to withstand the that the internet will do to you as like
an attractive woman. Yeah. Obviously.
Obviously. Like there needs to be enough neglect and trauma in
your life to need to make money this way. Yeah. And that's not
every hot girl. Okay. You know what? No matter how stupid you
are. I I know that sounds misogynistic,
but I I'm sorry. It's true. If you have pretty privilege, it's
it's great. Women have it very easy on the internet. Yes, you
have to deal with haters who
reminder, there are women who are literally crippled, who are
like down on their luck, willing to show people a slip of [__]
to pay their bills. That is not having it easy.
You could not fathom legendary legend lugging. You could not
fathom lugging your cast up a flight of stairs just so your chat
can accidentally see your so you don't get banned but you get
money. That's crazy. Don't want to, you know, listen to your
opinion because you're a woman. However, you will just have people
listen to everything you say and not give a about your opinion
because they're currently jerking off to you, paying you tens
of thousands of dollars, which is great. Now, it's not every
woman, but you al So great that uh he learned from the denim's
comments. So great easier due to the fact that you you can just
go on any other streamer stream. I mean look at like someone
like Miskf, you know what I mean? Uh or like
has anybody else like Msk does this? You know, you have somebody,
they're an only fans girl. You bring them on stream, they have
200 viewers when you first put them on on your stream and then
bada bing, bada boom, now they have a,000, 2,000, 3,000 just
cuz they're hot and they got to a streamer trim. You know, maybe
that goes on with other streamers in the LA stream. I'm going
to be real. I try very hard not to watch other people's streams.
I hate 99.99%
of other streams. I hate n Why is he just lying?
H how how is he pretending that when
uh Chud and a bunch of other people sorry not me I should say
Riyle because it was my VOD. But when when Riyle posts a video
of me Tee Tone in the YouTube comments when Chud posts a video
techone techone's in the YouTube comments. When Quayman posts
a video, Teone, Tees in the YouTube comments, how in the world
is he saying he doesn't watch other streamers when he sits there
name searching for any criticism so he can go and talk or like
pretend it doesn't bother him in the comments. This is
so bizarre. This is so bizarre. 99.99%
of other streamers as content creators as well as people. Yeah,
I I don't really like too many people. No, I used to. I I really
did used to, but I'll get more into that later. So the other
way to be successful as a stream. He leaves one comment, doesn't
watch the videos. The comments themselves have nothing to do
with the content of the videos. No, they often do. They often
do. Is you do a lot of dick sucking. A lot a lot of dick. It
depends on what the criticism is, right? And depends on how offputting
their thumbnail is. But he keeps track of all of them. And he
comments on a lot of the Pizooku's videos, too. Sucking. You
see this a lot in the VTuber sphere. You see this a lot in the
LA scene. Everybody's got to be friends with everybody. Everything
somebody else is. Oh my god, this is so cool. Oh my god, my Oshi.
Oh my god, everything is so great. Oh my god, there's no drama
ever. Oh my god, I love everybody. I love everybody. Please do
things with me. And I think that leads a lot of VTubers to be
doing a lot of collabs with a lot of people they don't with.
And I think that leads to a lot of mask off moments like we saw
with Cinder
because everybody's got to be a dick sucker. And where Cinder's
mask fell off, there's a 100 more streamers just like them waiting
to take their place. I so badly need that clip of Hassan now.
I so badly need that clip. We're like, excuse the Hassan jab
just to maintain that bridge. I need it so badly now. But a lot
of them, you got to understand, there's just no way that anybody
is actually going to wake up at that golden retriever energy
saying, "I love this. I love that. I love this. I love that."
And then streamers in the Vtubing space get so much hate the
moment they start talking about some real because there's so
much fantasy pretend Mickey Mouse. Everybody's happy. Everybody
loves each other. It's sickening. It's sickening. I don't know
how people buy into that. But to be honest, I'm still shocked
that people are actively choosing to watch VTuber that don't
have a big old pair of jugs cuz that's the only reason why I
watch him to begin with anyways. Oh, now he's lying about about
always loving Lolly, too. Hold on. Somebody get me the clip.
Hold on. I don't know if I don't know if Cherry saw the clip.
Let me get Let me get the clip. Let me get the clip. Uh there's
this one. Yes, this was the one from Shimu.
Next up. Yeah. Yeah.
Dude, I feel like if Palon were to visit me, I feel like we'd
just be best friends.
The Pon. You said the Pon character there. This this very young
looking character right here. Hold on. Not auto 1080p, please.
Hold on. We need this to rebuffer. Will it buffer? Hold on. Apparently
not. Thank you, Twitter video, for always breaking for like literally
always breaking. Dude, I feel like if Pon
were to visit me, I feel like we'd just be best friends. It's
not working. That's 360p again, isn't it? God damn it. You know,
and I bet she would taste delicious. Imagine I bet she would
taste delicious.
That anime thing.
Yeah, this girl right here. This girl right here. Hold on. We're
not done. We're not done. Pmon's feet would taste when she's
18.
So, first we'd be best friends.
I bet she'd taste delicious. I bet her feet would taste delicious
when she turns 18.
Why does he wait until now to say when she turns 18? Uh, because
he probably realizes how he looks a little bit. Imagine how Pon's
feet would taste when she's 18. Probably like cinnamon and honey.
As
cinnamon and honey, but he said when she's 18. Yeah. Does that
help when somebody says that about like your nine-year-old niece
and then they say, "But when she's 18," is that is that a saver?
Does that save that comment for you? Man, that girl's feet would
taste delicious when she turns 18. You're pointing at a like
Why do you Why do you say that out loud? Why are those thoughts
that don't like just like die in your brain? I don't know. It
was a cartoon. It is a cartoon. That's a weird thought to put
out there. But now that's Hold on. This is the whole thing where
he's like, "The only reason I'd ever watch a VTuber is cuz she
got huge." Like, "Nobody believes you, right? Nobody believes
you. Nobody believes you. Nobody believes you." It's great. Although
I say that and it's like, "Try to name five successful male YouTubers."
Go ahead. 30. You have 30 seconds. Name five successful male
YouTubers. Yeah, it's kind of hard to do, huh? Let me see. Shodo,
Athlan. Yeah, Lord Athlan. That's the only guy I know cuz he
married Nanners.
Not give up. Yeah, that's all I know. Uh, wait.
Rev is like that's a dude who is is a VTuber of a little girl,
so that doesn't count.
Uh, but he's a dude. Nukaku. Holy. He's a VTuber.
I didn't even think of that. Yeah, but he didn't really succeed
in the normal VTubing way. You know what I mean? Although then
again, I suppose neither did Nathan stand. Nux is I guess a Dude,
you know what's crazy? I'm soed up in the head. I've known Nu
for so long. I legit just thought he was this blue,
you know, the blue from Gintama.
No, there actually a Wait, is there a blue in Gintama? Human
behind that. Holy. Now I get Now I get the mental illness cuz
I knew his back in co that that was peak brain round. Oh, the
AC stopped. May you you might you guys might be able to hear
me now. That's crazy. So yes, one being an attractive female.
Two, be a dick sucker. Three, ladder climber.
any other streamer that has success. You go, you talk to them,
you get buddy buddy, you chill in their chat, you hope to God
you get a collab, you hope to God you get a raid, this, that,
and the other. Jesus,
everybody's going to pretend to be everybody's friend. But then
the moment any controversy happens, you will find out who your
real friends are very quickly.
You will find out who still wants you on their stream. Most persecuted
man on the internet right here, guys.
Nobody stuck by him when uh he had those multiple
assault allegations or his dad. Okay? Nobody's treated anybody
in this family. Well, you will find out who wants to talk to
you in the DMs.
You will find out who is actually there for you, which one of
your friendships,
you know,
are real and which one's not.
And you'll learn that very quickly. It's very easy to play pretend.
It's very easy to ladder climb. It's very easy to be fake as
it's very easy to fain kindness towards somebody who holsters
nothing but benefit to you.
But the moment,
and I mean the moment, that you are of a 1% detriment,
a slight
maybe an uncomfortable talk you have to have with your chat,
you will toss these people to the wayside
and you will never look back and you will never feel bad because
at the end of the day, all these is he copying Asthma Gold's
videos here? I believe he is. Is this self-reflection? I don't
think he's capable. [__] streamers. All these content
creators only give a about one thing and that's themsel. You
see these streamers blow up. You have the ladder climbers and
you also have the ladder pullers.
Those are great. You got a lot of those going on in the not that
a lot of my new audience cared, but one of the reasons why I
hate the Oh, I almost said a slur. I'm so glad I didn't say that.
Sorry. We're getting a little bit too real here. Uh what the
what? Wait, what did he Did he come close? hate the Oh, I almost
said a slur. No, you didn't. There's literally no like what
one of the reasons why I hate the Oh, I almost said a slur. There's
not even a There's not even a pause. I'm so glad I didn't say
that. Sorry, we're getting a little bit too real here. Uh, you
know, we're not Yeah, not real. He's so real. Okay. How many
collabs has he done with black creators? Do we know off top of
you guys' heads? He done a lot of collabs with people of color.
Is it mostly just white dudes in Austin? Word. I wasn't gonna
say the super one. Yeah, the the gay ass Genjin community. There's
so many people that succeed. Oh, the Okay. And I was the most
successful Genchin Impact content creator of all time.
And when I succeeded, like I have been doing for 6 and 1/2 years,
I immediately made it a point to bring up as many other people
with me as I could
because that's that's what I do. That's what I care about. But
I like Let me guess. And I think authentic. Well, I think there's
some there's some uh what do you call it? Uh I think he's going
to say and those people that I tried to bring up, those people
that I trusted, those people that I thought were my friends,
they tried to cancel me in the end or some like that. I'm pretty
sure growing other people. Well, it doesn't matter. It just you
you know it's coming from a good place when
you bring it up later to show people how good of a person you
are. Yeah. Exactly. That's why I do like showing your charity
receipts. Yeah. Could you imagine not doing a good deed and recording
it? Like just like like doing a good deed and then not recording
proof of that good deed.
Could you imagine? Like how would you ever prove that you did
that good deed? Yeah. How would any of these people know how
good of a person I am? Yeah. It would be so weird because that's
that's what I do. That's what I care about. I like growing other
people's streams. That's why I work so heavily with mythic talent.
So I like bringing money to creators. I like bringing success
to creators. I like having people who I can cherish in this world.
And I do. Oh, no. No. You know,
you know what this sounds like? This actually sounds like MLM.
Like you when half of your product is actually just like selling
all of the Mary Kay supplies to other people, but telling them
like I live for creating other independent business people or
whatever. I I like making it so that other people they can live
the same freedom that I do and like earn an income without having
to work a 9 to5. Like I live for that. But would it really be
valuable to create like a
system of like smaller streamers who would be feel who would
feel like indebted to you and feel like they have to have your
back? Would that would there be any actual value to that and
that none of them none of them are even an inch as successful
as you are?
Hm. I hadn't thought about that. Interesting. But trust me, for
every friend that I've had, I've uh lost 20 or 30. And that's
just a common thread of life. That's something that you guys
are going to realize. The friends that you have in
Sounds like MLM.
Oh, he's doing the right now.
Oh, 18% retention rate. Yes, he's literally doing the Arcadum
right now. like uh it's crazy.
Hold on. No, but this is like the success rate of like any other
person who's like selling MLM,
right? It's like, okay, there are like 30 people that get into
debt or they just like blew $200 trying to like sell this product,
but like there's always this one person
that makes it and they stick with it. And then you look at that
person, that person is never successful.
They just like are a ride or die forever. Is is Tee that guy
or is are the people under Tee that person because I feel like
Tee doesn't actually Teone doesn't believe in the product. You
know what I'm saying? Like Yeah. That's why everybody like fails,
right? He's saying he loses like 30 friends, but uh there's always
going to be some success stories. There's always going to be
like some friends that he doesn't lose. Those are all the people
who don't make money doing the thing that he was supposedly like
helping them do, right? Oh, yes. Sure. But also, I was gonna
say all the people who are successful, like actually successful
with MLMs are always the worst people, unfortunately.
Like I Yes. And then I would say the people who are successful
who are friends of his like it's not that he brought them up,
right? He just met them streaming.
Yeah.
They were going to know what to do with his friendship and or
they were going to make it without him regardless, right? Because
they are they have that like narcissistic drive. Yeah. As Gold's
there, too. Damn. Damn. Not that Asminold does the same thing.
I don't think Asmin Gold really collabs with Asminold kind of
is just on his own trash island. Okay. But Asmin Gold is his
friend because uh he was just always gonna be here too. Yeah,
true. Friend that I've had, I've Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. I need to go back. A lot of great friends.
But trust me, for every friend that I've had, I've uh lost 20
or 30. And that's just a common thread of life. That's something
that you guys are going to realize. The friends that you have
in elementary school, you're not going to have them in middle
school. The friends you have in middle school, you're not going to
have in high school. And the friends that you have in high school,
you're not going to have in college. The friends in college,
you might have foreseable future you guys move too far apart.
And then you'll you'll fade. You'll talk every now and then on
DMs, but it'll fade. And it's the same thing with content created
friends and discord friends. The moment you stop playing the
same games, the moment you stop going places, the moment it stops
for these people, you will lose them.
Now I'm very
um That needs to be clipped. That needs to be clipped and posted.
That is so accurate. That's insane.
It's It is accurate, dude. This guy Okay, that last part, he
like brought it back around to like a decent point, which is
you probably won't maintain friendships with people that you
don't do things with. But that's just that's true of all of life.
And it doesn't mean somebody's bad. It just means that that's
how human beings are. You're friends with the people in proximity
to you. There are very few it's almost impossible to keep friends
who you don't do things with. you move to a different country
from one of your best friends, you will eventually fall out of
touch with them. Like almost
this is every spoiled streamer that's like, "Dude, I tried to
make it easy for him to still play video games with me. I don't
understand if he can't come around. I guess that's fine." And
then here's your friend. He's like, "Bro, I have to make rent.
You literally play 12 hours a day and you're making bank off
of this. I can't even make rent." Isn't this like didn't X have
a similar similar issue or something like that? He like paid
Brent for one of his friends for a little bit. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I remember that. That happened and then just and was like this
guy's a bum and he doesn't figure hisit out and it's like okay
this
I don't know. I don't know. They're manchildren.
They make millions playing video games and they can't imagine
why why their friends just like come and go. Can't imagine. Very
top goal meme in stream chat. No, this is not topical. This is
You guys are Nope. The Ring of Winter. What is this?
Laura inaccurate skin tone. Am I the black elf?
Yes, obviously. I If you guys miss You guys missed it. Okay.
Most people would have missed Cherry explaining like what was
happening in different fantasy series. Yeah. No, Sophia, you
missed it earlier. Okay. Cherry was explaining what was happening
in different fantasy series and it was up. Okay. She was trolling.
so hard and I just didn't react. This is the winter part. You
go through um you have to go through at the bottom is winter
with the white walkers and you climb up the mountain to where
the fire is so you can throw the ring into the fire
for the song of like fire and ice. Yeah, basically. More or less.
And he thinks that black elves can't be there because the black
elves should never go through the cold. Something like that.
They would they just wouldn't like the cold. Yeah, that's it.
Yeah. Yeah, I'm very prideful because I can count on more than
two hands. The amount of lifelong friends that I've had, real
friends, people that are there no matter what, that are above
the noise who don't care because that's how they get you. And
that's my biggest weakness is they get you because they they
care
and you will be weak if you care too much. Thankfully, I've already
experienced the worst of it, you know. Why the did I stop playing
the music? Actually, holy [__] Count on more than
two hands. the amount of lifelong friends that I've had, real
friends, that people that are there no matter what, that are
above the noise, who don't care, because that's how they get
you. And that's my biggest weakness is they get you because they
they care.
And you will be weak if you care too much. Thankfully, I've already
experienced the worth of it. You know, I got people going after
me for my dad. And don't get me wrong, I understand what my dad
did with dad, right? But people are greatly exaggerating what
he did just so they could take down a pet. Okay, it doesn't do
[__] You don't
If he if he ends this video saying and that's why I don't play
Among Us, I would s I would suck his micro,
okay? Cuz that means that this is all just hilarious.
But I actually think that this is just real. I think he's actually
whining right now. He see he this is how he sees the whole world.
He is like the biggest victim. It's so funny. I don't understand
how the audience keeps growing. It's amazing. His dad didn't.
Yeah. When people call his dad a It's because they are literally
like doing the thing on the internet that we all do. Like when
somebody calls someone a It's not literally a Right. They're
not
they're like
knows his dad. He just Look what he said after. He's just meing.
Five counts of
Five counts of assault. Five counts of assault. Anyway, this
guy like uh really just wants to be on techone side. I don't
trolling, I guess.
I feel like I've started justing most
troll people who actually have no actual opinions, but we'll
see. No, he's like unironically trolling. I know. You know what
all that did? It got me to a million subscribers on YouTube.
Go yourself. Go suck my
making fun of his dad. Okay. Saying that his dad is a That got
him to a million subs on YouTube. Okay. Did it have a an effect
on his dad? He hasn't asked. Okay. But actually got him to a
million subs on YouTube. That's what we care about, guys. What
he did just so they can take me down a peg, brother. It doesn't
do [__] You know what all that did? It got me to
a million subscribers on YouTube. Go yourself. Go suck my dick.
You can sit there. It also got us to hear your stories about
how you were as a kid and then how your dad held a gun to your
temple, which nobody knew about, by the way. So, w techone. Okay.
And then you cried and then you said the reason you were crying
was because of Hosanabi. And then you snapped out of crying in
like a millisecond, popped a in your mouth, went I'm just going
to keep farming him then.
I This is the most unserious person on the entire internet. It's
actually crazy. You can have your fun. You can spread your misinformation.
You can talk about me. You can talk about what my ex said. And
did you hear what he did back in Arc Knights? Did you hear what
he did back in Genchin Impact? Unfortunately for all these on
the internet, we're moving towards a uh new era where people
are actually getting this doing a Google search. They're realizing
that I have done nothing but tell the truth for 6 and 1/2 years.
And that's why I get into so much. That's why so many hate me.
I succeeded.
Remember when he said he was going to post receipts that showed
that uh Pinky was lying and then he just didn't and then he just
pretended that didn't happen. Guys, he has never told a lie.
He just keeps telling the truth, guys. He's a truceayer. Okay.
By telling No. And then he blamed it. He also then blamed it
on the fact that she went to the police.
Like, oh, because she went to the police, I can't actually prove
it to you guys. Yeah. I'm in a lawsuit now. I couldn't possibly
just post like exculpatory evidence. If I post exculpatory evidence,
my lawyer tells me they won't even allow He didn't say this.
Me making it up. Uh they won't even let us use that in court.
I can't do that, guys. He just acted like this is the the most
up thing that she did and why can't we just handle this on the
internet? As if like the biggest attack would have been, "Oh
yeah, if it was really why didn't you go to the police?" Yeah,
exactly dude. Yeah, you're damned if you do, damned if you don't,
right?
Yep. It's like so stupid. Oh, uh, you haven't gone to the police.
Well, I guess you're just a lying [__] Well, you
went to the police. Well, why isn't anything happening right
now? Why? Why aren't they doing something right now? No, I can't
talk about this anymore except to call you a lying [__]
a thousand more times. Okay, I can't I can't The evidence I said
I can post. No, I can't post that now. My My lawyer said so.
But this is this lies. Okay. She lies about everything. Nobody
trusts her.
Amazing. Amazing. And it's hard. It is cuz sometimes the truth
doesn't make you look good. I succeeded while taking accountability
for my actions. I succeeded
for showing remorse when I [__] up.
And I succeeded. Wait, where was the remorse? I don't know. Do
you remember, by the way, remember? Do you remember when he had
that insanely like abusive uh that insanely abusive looking fight
with his wife? You guys remember that?
When he was the conflict resolution god.
Oh, I lined that up perfectly on my end with your voice, by the
way. The soundboard lined up one to one with your voice right
there. You love to see it. Okay. Remember when he said that that
was because he found out his wife was cheating on him and so
that's why he was being a complete there, right? Like that's
why he was like being so passive aggressive and so angry at her
and then she just posted receipts showing I think we do about
50/50. You're high.
Yeah. Yeah. That one. And then so and then his wife posted receipts
being like, "I didn't even meet that person till like a month
after this." So he just lied completely about that. He just made
it up. Cool. By apologizing. Accountability.
That's not how content creation works.
robot in the political space. You can't ever talk about emotive.
You can't ever cry. You can't ever get angry.
You cried literally a month ago. Literally like two months ago.
Maybe a month and a half ago. Tops. You literally cried. You
literally cried and then you gained 200,000 subs. What are we
doing? What What are we doing? You don't understand. He's a couple
people said bad things about him. So this is like cancel culture.
Forget the parts where he's clearly saying he wasn't cancelled
and he's only grown continued to grow because of it. But let
him wear the badge of I was a cancel culture victim. I uh it
none of it makes sense. None of it like it's so it's so ass backwards.
It's crazy.
You got to be calm. You got to be like a robot. Any criticism
that comes your way, you got to deflect. You got to change the
narrative. You got to attack arguments that don't exist. got
to make it right. You can't own who you are. You just got to
be what the machine wants you to be. And that's all it ever is.
Harrowing how many content creators I'll watch on stream. And
then I'll meet him off stream and I'm just like, damn, you are
just like not the same at all. That's some of the people who
I care about so much. Naku the real a real man. He is he's a
great guy. Uhhuh. And I I don't even know if these people understand
how much I act care about them because I I I will admit I'm pretty
bad at DMing. I am. And to be honest, I'm okay with that. I don't
really need to talk to everybody every day.
I like the occasional phone call, the occasional DM, but like
it is difficult talking all the time. People like Nucks, man.
Just such good people. People like Asmin Gold, you know? Nux
is the exact same on stream off stream, which I love. Asthma
Gold's a little bit different. And that's kind of one of the
reasons why I've just been so frustrated with content creating
because obviously I mean you guys know I've been a big fan of
as for a long time. I've had the honor of being in the same or
as him doing a podcast. I respect them so goddamn much. It's
ridiculous.
Dude, I I'm looking for anything to He's literally talking about
nothing. He's just there's nothing going on. This is that Listen,
I've never been more certain in my entire life that he is FTM,
right? I'm sorry. This is like literally how women tell stories.
He woke up. He had a point to make and he's gone on a hundred
different tangents here. Okay, I'm sorry. Maybe it's
We haven't ruled it out. And he is a little bit different off
stream. He is He's a lot more soft felt. He's a lot more uh you
know, a lot more u I don't know, a lot more human when he goes
live on big hilarious. Love seeing that. But it's crazy to see
a guy get so much It's crazy to see a guy get so much [__]
while being one of the best people that I know. Same thing with
Emmy. Emmy gets so much one of the best people I know. Nicholas
Light gets so much one of the best people I know. Shina gets
so much
one of the best people I know. I could keep going. And it's crazy
how I have all these friends who are considered just pieces of
and they're just such good down to earth people. Donut operator,
the unsubscribed podcast. Uh Noxtock is a complete piece of obviously.
I mean holy these guys invite I mean I'm not I'm not even going
to try to get emotional, but these guys invited me to spend fourth
of July with them off stream. [__] make me so happy,
bro. I feel I feel so blessed in this world. I know a lot of
people see my journey through content creation. And they say,
"Holy, how do you do it?" I know this may not may not make sense
to y'all, but I thrive.
I thrive on hatred. It's bad. Dude, this is
No, this is
This is This is the Hassan. The Kardashians are lying to you.
He just decided to that video for himself. Okay, this is like
as cringey as that Hassan video. The Kardashians are lying to
you. I seek out critic. Oh, wait. Those might be different videos
now that I think about it. But the I seek out criticism thing
from Aison. It's like the same exact concept. I seek out criticism.
No, you don't. I don't know. This This guy's like, "I thrive
on hate." No, you don't. You literally cried when Hassan said,
"You may be a because your dad was a You actually cried.
You cried." But I feel like you already hit the nail on the hammer.
Is that it? That's the saying, right? Hit the nail on the head.
I knew something fell off. I just I feel like you nailed it when
you brought up the arcade music because that's just everything.
That's the that encompasses everything here. He actually just
started veering off and saying, "Yeah, I don't mind if people
don't keep in touch. You don't hear from people after a while."
Nick, you just started talking about how
30 people don't talk to you anymore
when after you like try to help them.
You seriously do care. What are you talking about? Streaming
with them. They'll stop talking to you. they'll fall off. And
then he was like, "Yeah, I don't I'm actually I'm not the best
texter. I'm not the best DMER." Yeah. No. And so as soon when
he thinks about all of the people that never talk to him anymore,
don't come around and play video games anymore that he's like
broken. Like these people. But then he thinks about how much
he probably doesn't really talk to Asmin Gold or anything. And
then he's like, "Yeah, I don't need people to talk to me all
the time." Okay.
Okay, buddy.
Crazy. Would you believe we're only 14 minutes into a 30 minute
video? Sherry, could you imagine? What the else could he have
to say? Uh, I'm not totally sure. Guys, chill.
What is wrong with you guys? Yeah, I don't know why they're trying
to Why Why are you guys trying to do that right now? I think
Meow inspired it and then people can't kill themselves. You just
do like uh what? Five minute timeouts for people. Don't do it.
Don't do it. I don't think I wonder if Meow even meant to. Oh,
were you a long one time out? Apparently, you stopped there when
you were like or something. I probably did. Sometimes I stop
saying a word, but I wasn't gonna say [__] I don't
have the I don't have the soundboard. Oh, where is it?
I need to drink water. Where's my vibr? It wasn't on the first
one. Yeah, it should be stronger. I will just be your paint pig.
Oh, hold on. Reban Ruben donated $5. Quick Tik Tok react in stream
chat Plaza. Uh Reuben Ruben wants me to react to a Tik Tok that
he put in stream chat apparently. Hold on. Okay, I'll check it
out.
Rubber duckies,
give me the creeps.
Stop it.
You're supposed to not be able to hear it, Cherry. What are you
doing? What are you doing, dude? I once dated a guy who when
he moved in with me, he brought rubber that Do we want to expand
on that story at all anymore? No, it didn't work out. I can't
imagine why. I cannot imagine.
Cannot imagine why. Oh, 10 years older than me. I just wanted
to get that out there. That was important to get out there. That
was uh 10 years older
Good decision.
Cool. He's my boss and he um moved in with me and brought rubber.
Triple cool. All right. He's really hot. Didn't make up for anything
else that he was lacking, though. Don't date for looks, you guys.
Okay, so where are we going? Oh, I was going to show guys. If
you like the content, you go ahead. You can add some time to
the stream. You can uh you can do a couple different things.
Okay. You can Oh, you should follow on every platform. Follow
on Twitter and join the Discord. discord.gg/jk.
I think we've had like a 30 person VC going for most of the stream.
So, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. All right,
join the Discord. And if you want to add more time to the stream,
go ahead. You can sub on kick. You can sub individually on kick.
I really love individual subs because they give me like rolling
income. It's a recurring sub each month. I super appreciate everybody
who subs individually. Okay, really appreciate it. Would love
if everybody everybody subbed individually. If you want to just
give money, give more uh time on the stream. You can give subs
on kick. That's the best split. 955 goes directly into my pocket.
You can gift uh one sub, two subs, three subs, five subs, 10.
Okay, doesn't matter. If you don't want to do that, if you want
to have a TTS message right on screen, exclamation point donate
in the chat or the pin message in Kickhat will give you the Kickbot
link and or the Streamlabs link. $3 minimum Streamlabs, $2 minimum
on Kickbot. All right. And last but not least, there's the Patreon.
Uh we'll see if we end if we end without another hour on the
stream. We'll do an oiler call after this. Maybe we'll do that.
Uh maybe we'll go through that airite video on Mango. Wouldn't
you love to see how that would go? We could do that for oiler
call. I think that would be pretty sweet. Okay, so
couple different tiers here. We got the oiler tier prestream,
post stream content. All right. Couple different nights a week.
Well, sorry. Couple different nights a month. I meant to say
month month. We've gotten back into it. We had an early call
the other night. Unfortunately, it was at like 2 a.m. and basically
nobody basically nobody showed up. I was just like, "Okay, it's
just me and you talking." All right, I'll keep talking to you.
But hey,
you see the AB and Preach video, Mango? Nope, not yet. Anyway,
so we could go over some of that stuff in the other call. This
time wouldn't be at like 3:00 in the morning. Okay, the last
one was kind of annoying. When Jay start to say a hard slur,
that's 100 bucks. It is not 100 bucks. Okay, so we I think we
have $45 for another hour on the stream. We have I think $8 so
far. So that's like seven subs.
Sevenish subs. Yeah, we'll do seven subs for another hour on
the stream. Okay. All right. Thank you for listening to this
show. I'll show again probably at like 15 minutes or something.
So, let's get back to the TechTome video. Yeah.
Are they recorded for Patreon? I can record some things. I don't
record everything because sometimes it's like uh nicer to just
have a relaxed environment. So, I could record this one if I'm
going to do content do like $5.
We can never record if I'm reacting to Aerodite. Oh, but yeah.
Okay. So, not that one. So, no. Unlucky for you. So, you'd have
to sign up yourself and watch live. Okay. We're continuing on
with the techone content. I will say slurs. Jesus. Go on. Hit
bad. There are so many. I can't I'm not going to make a joke
on that. You wonder why that is because there's so many things.
Oh, sure, sure, sure. Hold on.
So many things in this world that I hate. You want to know why
that is? Because there's so many things on this world that deserve
to be hated.
There's so much bad
happens every single day and you're considered toxic. You're
considered negative if you just look at it say, "Hey man, that's
up. Let's fix it." Everybody wants to ignore it. Let everybody
else do the dirty for them. There's like these privileged
there's so many people where techone is Yeah.
I just like if Ry if you were here like rip this entire dude's
video and just put this arcade of music in the background and
then end it with a clip of him saying anyone what did he say?
Anyone play Among Us? Wait, what did he say? And this is why
I don't play Among Us. This is why I don't play Among Us. Yes.
Yes. Among Us.
God. Uh what is this guy talking about? He's literally just victimizing
himself. He's just victimizing himself over and over again. No,
he's You don't I said it should just be 10 minutes of this video.
That's like more than enough. It's But rough to watch. He's spitting.
This is what it feels like. This is how you get You just wouldn't
understand probably until you listen to 32 minutes of this what
it's like to actually be like so successful. you make like $400,000
a month and
um
the life is at your fingertips
and
really like nobody can ever get you on anything. Your dad's um
and he's still out free.
Um it's just difficult and that's what he's trying to communicate
here and you just don't understand. I'm sure it is hard and you're
micro. Okay. Well, it's not that hard cuz it you still have like
a a problem with your dick or whatever. It's kind of hard. Yeah.
Just to be clear, she's talking about Teone. She's trying to
say you should empathize with Techone for these reasons. She's
not talking about me. Okay. No, no, no. Just want to make that
very clear for everybody. See these soldiers on the front line
dying for that. Oh, he's Oh, nice. Nice. Sorry. I paused there
to say, "Dude, Tech's just coming over to some conversation."
He's like, "Guys, I just want to I just want to fix it. I want
to have a positive conversation about a constructive solution
to this problem." And then everybody's like, "Off Teone, off
Techone. Off Teone." That's how that's how his life goes. Okay?
That's how he does it. Everybody wants to ignore it. Let everybody
else do the dirty for them. Just like these privileged
see these soldiers on the front line dying for them while damning
the actions that they take to keep their citizens safe, to keep
the civilians safe. Oh, it's so bad, bro.
Bro, I'm sorry. We don't need a drone strike a random goat herder
in Pakistan. Sorry, Pakistan. Yeah, Pakistan to keep us safe
in North America. Okay, it's not happening. There's like the
the overreach got insane. Okay, why are we pretending that like,
oh, there are no problems there. There's nothing to criticize.
They're perfectly healthy criticism. There's perfectly healthy
criticism to be made. Is this not every like
military
uh serviceman's like nightmare
that they're going off into war and then there's some like soy
boy loser who sits at home and jacks off to anime that thinks
that like they're really about that life and they start talking
like they're in the military.
Yeah. Well, his family's in the military. Okay. His
colonel. His dad retired at Colonel, actually. Yeah, that's even
worse. So, you're just like the son of somebody who went in the
military, but you sit at home and you play your little girl boy
girl video games and you talk to your friends online about what
this little wee girl's feet taste like when she's underage
and then the next moment you're sitting here in a wife beater
talking like you're about that life. I want to watch him goofy.
I want to watch him and his dad and his serviceman brothers watch
that video of him talking about sucking that nine-year-old girl's
toes. Okay. I want I want to watch them watch that old cartoon
cartoon girl's toes. He's not even a real woman. Yeah. Yep.
Would love to see it. My dad retired as a colonel. I'm not talking
about that crap. Yeah, I know. Uh
it's so crazy that he didn't get busted Well, it's so crazy that
his dad didn't get busted down rank or anything. They just let
him retire like full ranks. Literally the face of stop military
and yeah that is actual culture.
Did you not see his dad's reaction? Um wait schumafine I'm talking
about to the toe sucking clip. Unless you're talking about that
link it here. Actually Schumafine I'm going to let you take an
hour off and you if you get that clip for me I will watch it.
Throw in the Discord. He's talking about the VR. Yeah. Oh his
dad looking at the VR. No. I know what he's talking about. It's
something different, but it's his dad reacting to VR.
Yeah, it's not remotely the same thing. It's like a actual adult
looking woman, not a nine-year-old looking little girl. So, obviously
that is the more off-putting part there. Go find a clip of Teone
professing his love for a lolly girl to his dad. Okay. And then
I will unttime out or just wait. No, I'm I'm going to unttime
out. I was making comments about how military people would feel
about some dude who plays with these video games. their wee video
games and stuff like that talking this is kind of relevant to
what I was saying. Okay, that's your choice.
Okay, well freedom is not I want to kill people and Cherry just
keeps saving them. It's not free. You have the nice one today
and I don't want to see anybody casting judgment on anybody else
fighting for our freedom. Whether you agree or disagree with
the means you can go [__] yourself. Does suck that
I don't like games as much as I used to anymore. But then again,
I'm sure when it around I'll enjoy it. Hold on. Thank you. You
have to fight for this. And I don't want to see anybody casting
judgment on anybody else who's fighting for our freedom. Whether
you agree or disagree with the means, you can go yourself. Does
suck that I don't like games as much as I used to anymore. But
then again, I'm sure when a good game comes around, I'll enjoy
it. Oh my god. But right now, the thing about No, he's doing
it on purpose, right? No, he's doing it on purpose. That's what
he Arcam literally says. He doesn't enjoy this anymore. I'm I'm
going to lose my
I'm going to lose my He's plagiarizing.
I'm seeing through the Matrix, Sherry. Okay, I call these things
right off the bat now. I just tell you what's going to h You
don't even have to Guys, we don't have to keep up with these
people. I can just say, "Listen, Lwig's just upset that he's
going to have to listen to Cutie Cinderella and tell them how
long it is." Okay, I just I'll call it and it'll happen. Let's
go. Which is great. It didn't always used to be this way. I've
made a you know, a lot of mistakes. I've picked a Well, you know,
I've had a lot of lady issues. I think I finally got a good one.
I'm very happy every time I go off stream. I really enjoy spending
my time with my girls. I enjoy a lot of time. Okay. Over under
6 months until there's a lawsuit here as well. Over under six
months, guys. Lawsuit.
I'm going to take the over. Oh. Uh or investigation. Okay. Or
or report made. What? Uh I'm going to go with STD. Oh, STD. Oh,
maybe. Maybe. Maybe. I could see it. Yeah. I'm sure my dog and
my kitties. I never thought my life would be this way. I never
thought I could actually find happiness again, you know, like
this much for this long. I always live my life thinking, "How
long is it going to last?" But I don't see I don't I don't see
any red flags up coming. I don't see it. Before I used to see
it. I said, "Ah, man. This one's so pretty, but man, she's nuts.
When's it going to go wrong?" Or this one's got big jugs, but
my god, I hate this. I'm What? Would you actually just stay with
somebody because big Well, Teone would, which is weird because
Teone doesn't even find women attractive. Like, it's very strange.
He literally can't get hard thinking about penetrating a woman.
I thought he It's because he can't
It's like you can't put yourself into the scene, right? If you
[__] get hard thinking about penetrating somebody
if you have a micro uh Maybe I'm not I really am not sure. The
Arcadm. Yeah, we're aware of the Arcadam clip. We can play it
after for We do have to. Yeah, we do. Yeah. Do Well, do you want
to I We pause now. Should we go now to show people? Yeah. Do
it now and then and then the second half
cuz I swear to God if he says Why do we get a Destiny clip? Yeah.
Why do we have to have this version?
Can we just get the actual He might be the only iteration that
they have. He's definitely not. He's definitely not. He's definitely
not. There's like a literally a streamable that has like all
for one clips in it,
bro. I
That's crazy. It's fine. We'll go back to it. Somebody will find
it eventually. [__] I had another one. It was actually
pretty good. I'll just say Elena. Elena was a great girlfriend.
That was way back in the day. That was back in college. She was
great. But I mean this generally. She was way too aggressive.
She She wasing me way harder than I her and I was like, damn,
I can't handle this. I never really like sex. Wait, what did
he just say? I was She was great. I mean, generally she was way
too aggressive.
She She wasing me way harder than I her and I was like, "Damn,
I can't handle this." I Okay, I Okay, that's very Have you ever
Have you ever like bounced on a guy and you know there's nothing
to bounce on? Just like if you do it harder Never mind. I'm just
imagining what the it means to him harder than he you. I don't
know. I
do not know. I I sorry. I don't know what you're talking. Yeah.
When you ask me that. Listen. Well, you weren't really asking
me. You were asking the chat, but they don't know either.
There's like two women in chat that I'm talking to. Yeah, some
people might. Oh boy. Oh boy. Never really liked until like,
you know, 31 this year. Yet they call me af.
Yeah. Jesus. It is insane, man. The truth doesn't matter anymore.
It doesn't. It's like the court. Truth doesn't matter. Only matters
what you can prove. And on the internet, the truth doesn't matter.
It only matter. I don't even like So I'm not a I would have died
long ago. Once many years ago, I allowed myself to become arrogant
and I became the most evil version of myself that I have. See,
I knew that this existed. I knew it. It disgusted me
because imagine,
you know me enough now that you know what my abilities are.
Imagine if they had no temperance and I was selfish. Imagine
the destruction that I could wreak. I was not a good person.
I wasn't.
And it was only because of my self realization
that thankfully my love for D and D outpaced my selfishness and
I was able to retemper myself.
But the thing is is that I know that my influence is palpable
and is naturally more destructive.
Recently I've been exposed to other people who also have that
power at differing degrees and specializations.
But from what I've noticed, with the exception of probably two,
mine is stronger than theirs, and I keep it in check. Did Arcanum
ever play te D and D with Teone? Is this a collab that we've
seen?
Is Teone one of the two? Because if I don't, I could really hurt
someone.
That's the tragedy that I live. My training prevents me from
being I don't have the luxury of being emotional.
It's just another adjustment that I have to do in my constant
state. No, I I'll wait till after this service that I live in.
That's why I don't talk about it. That's also why I don't play
Among Us. That one doesn't include the percentages, by the way.
Ultimate. Yeah, it doesn't include that. There's a much longer
version. Um there's like Yeah, there's a bunch of recordings
of him talking and to that girl. Dude, we actually do need like
the ultimate D and D
like game run.
Can't imagine who would go in that. I got no idea. I don't know.
I I I think it should be Arcadam. It should be Tech Town. It
should be Mr. Girl. And you know, you could just like fill in
the blank for the fourth one. I'm There's no one that I'm going
to specifically name or anything. Okay, that would be a run.
Yeah, I can imagine. Would be a run. God. H you just gave me
flashbacks to like streamer D and D. It's like actually the worst
[__] This another Oh. Oh, hold on. I mean, do do
you think that if you didn't This is This is a good one, too.
Wouldn't be friends with you like that's not the case. No, no,
no. I know that that's you. In fact, I can give you a percentage.
Um, it is actually uh I believe it is 17.8%
of the people that I run D and D for will continue to be my friends
once the game is done. Lella, I have that number for you. I have
made that calculation. I have made that calculation four separate
occasions. The evidence is empirical.
So, sorry. Uh, I believe it is 48% of you won't talk to me ever
again. Wait, what about the other?
Uh, seriously, asking him not a real friendship. Hilarious.
Now, those covers are probably going to be more bloated onto
the passivity due to my position as a streamer. I haven't done
the recalculations based off of that yet, but I can tell you
that the the use of DND in order to make friends has a 17. This
guy is good at getting pity. No, he's not. He barely he hugged
this girl and that hug was so uncomfortable for her that she
canceled him and he actually got cancelled and he actually never
made it back ever. Okay,
that no he is not good at getting pity. This did not work. This
was pretty bad. This is pretty rough. Okay, this is somebody
who actually got cancelled and realistically
did not get cancelled for like conduct that's way outside like
other people have done way worse than him and not gotten cancelled.
He
did he get cancelled or did he like literally decide that like
he only has 17.8%
friend retention and like throw in the towel? Uh I think he still
streams right now. Yeah, he streamed today. Dude, this is like
maybe the most legendary followoff ever.
Um to like 50 people, 23
uh 23 average viewers, 32 peak viewers,
minus six followers. His selling note may be the saddest thing
of all time. Like you go back to 2022, he's 200 viewers. Okay,
that's around this like just before it's all straight fall off
on his follower graph. Okay, but this is not from 200
from 200. No, no, no, no. This is after. This is just after this
happened. He was at thousands, wasn't he? Don't worry. Yes. Yes.
Don't worry. I'm going to I'm going to keep backing it up slowly
so we can see. Okay. 200. We see. Okay. Still just a straight
fall off. Straight fall off. Oh, this is interesting. saying
that it was flat for a little bit. Hold on. We keep creeping
backwards. Creeping backwards. Creeping.
Oh no. Creep backwards a little further. Creep backwards a little
no no.
10,000 average. That's okay. But it's more than just hugging.
He was like emotionally minding gaslighting this girl who I'm
He was seemed like she had problems herself. No,
I don't know that she had like the biggest I mean, she was Yeah,
probably some problem, but like I don't think she was like that
bad. Dude, this is like actually a fall-off that needs to be
studied so badly. It's
No, you have to start this video over cuz I couldn't even imagine
pretending to ask about these percentages. I would be laughing
in this face
like what? Dude, he had like a stable like a stable rise and
like he was stable at like four to 5,000 viewers for so long,
too. Like he had a real run. He was making real money and then
he just got nuked from orbit. He was never the content. So when
he lost his guests, he lost his audience. Ooh. I guess that's
like if if um Austin's show ever did something that made people
not want to go on, he would just be done, right?
Maybe. I think Austin can be content on his own. Like it's a
different thing. I'm talking about before he ever becomes content,
right? So if his if Austin's thing was just starting out for
like a year and then he went through heat and nobody wanted to
go on his show again, that he would have never lasted as a streamer.
No. Or did he have his own thing going on then?
I have no idea. I didn't watch So I didn't watch Twitch back
then, so I have no idea. This guy's like Wick. No, he's not at
all. They're trying to associate him. They're trying to associate
the type of stream that he was. Like the idea that I know when
you Well, Wick does get like an average of like
a a number like that and then he'll get like a whole bunch more
if big names are on his thing, right? So, in a way, he would
be like Wick. No, Wick even with his biggest names wasn't wasn't
hitting like like 200 or 300 viewers. I don't think this is like
I think dude I Oh, okay. I can understand the concept that what
you're saying is like oh he's not understanding on his own. But
like dude this is crazy this fall off. But that does explain
it though. The exact thing the like oh he can't invite people
on anymore. They don't want to go on anymore. He's just He must
have been good on his own though, right? I heard that he was
a really good DM but I never watch from him. They are epic.
God more about the percentages. 46.3.
What the is this talking about?
I didn't expect this one. This part here like when the like after
that falloff happens
like uh Hold on, hold on, hold on. Where was it? Here. I didn't
expect like was this Arcadem. He used to host D and D sessions
DM, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't expect that. When we went
back, we just had like this section right here and we had like
up to a thousand and it's like, oh, he's like he, you know, he
was doing okay,
but then we backed up to where he actually was like 5,000,
That's crazy. Why did people stop going on his stream? Because
this girl came out and said that he was like using D and D to
like try to build a relationship with her and it was really uncomfortable
and like they kind of sort of pseudo dated. It was really weird.
It was like a whole really weird thing. Yeah, it was bizarre.
God, the Arcadam Chronicles. What a crazy time. What a wild and
crazy time. Remember when OTV replaced Koibu with Arcadum because
Ko wasn't comfortable with genociding orcs?
Oh, really? That sucks. Is that why Arcadam had to die? I don't
know, dude. I
I wish I actually watched Twitch back then. Now I feel like I
missed so much.
But oh well. Okay, hold I'm going to back up and I'm going to
hit play on this and I'm going to get some water and use the
bathroom. I'll be right back and we'll keep going, guys. 40 minutes
left on the stream. We are seven subs away from another hour
on the stream. Don't forget. Okay, we will keep going for a long
long long
time. Anyway, we're going Hit and play. I mean, do do you think
that if you didn't do D and D that people wouldn't be friends
with you? Like, that's not the case. No, no, no. I know that
that's you. In fact, I can give you a percentage.
Um, it is actually uh I believe it is 17.8%
of the people that I run D and D4 will continue to be my friends
once the game is done. I have that number for you. I have made
that calculation. I have made that calculation four separate
occasions. The evidence is empirical.
So, sorry. Uh, I believe it is 48% of you won't talk to me ever
again. Wait, what about the others?
Passing messages, not a real friendship. Now, those numbers are
probably going to be more bloated onto the passivity due to my
position as a streamer. I haven't done the recalculations based
off of that yet, but I can tell you unequivocally
that the the use of DND in order to make friends has a 17.8%
retention rate. That's the tragedy that I live. So, I don't expect
you to.
Guys, donate.
Donate so we have more time on the stream.
The up part is 17.8% isn't even that bad. That's what everyone
was saying at the time when we like all reviewed this. Um,
dude, this is like this is Bosch. If Bosch actually was like
more interested in women than um animated uh horses or whatever,
goblins, little girls that are short and stacked. Yeah. Mhm.
Like this is how off it would be if somebody who spoke like that
felt like they needed to get women. Like why? I feel like she's
being finessed into giving a about this dude and he's like pulling
out every like actually this is how I can overpower you with
my facts and logic. I just don't understand. Oh, Vos can get
women. Goblin short sacks do not exist in our realm. Yeah, but
Vos gets women because he probably doesn't actually want women,
so he's probably not really doing this. He wants the the goblins
so he can keep his together for them. I was just I just had the
moment. You ever see the the meme? Hold on. You ever see this
meme? Hold on one second. Like, true or false? Vos gave up on
women after the Poppy situation. He's like, "They're never going
to catch me again. It's horses for life." I just had this I just
had this happen unironically.
I I heard this like popping. It sounded like somebody was banging
on a drum outside my my house. And I looked outside the window
and I had this moment unironically. I was like so annoyed. What
the is this sound just like pop pop repeatedly. It was it it
was this it was unironically this situation. It's Canada Day.
They're doing fireworks. Yeah, it's Canada Day. This literally
happened.
This literally happened.
Is that how it sounds? Close enough. I was I was so annoyed.
Yeah, I was so annoyed. I'm just like, what is happening outside?
Yeah, it's just fireworks for Canada Day, dude. Canada. Okay,
there are there is this one rapper that I love who is Canadian.
Uh kind of went to jail for Meg the Stallion. Uh no, I said rapper.
Wait, Toy Lens is Canadian. Yes, he is Canadian. And he's some
goofy ass Canadian because whenever he was on a track, he had
this thing that he would just say. He would go Canada. And it
was like it ruined that moment of the song. There was like a
a remix to Jack Carlos's What's Popping and this just yells and
I wanted to die every time I heard that. Oh. Uh, something about
whenever people make it known that they're from Canada, it's
like a vibe killer.
But happy Canada Day. Uh-huh.
Thank you. I'll just take I'll just take it. I'll just take it.
Understand that. I I don't bring it up because it just makes
people feel awful. But that's the reality of it. I mean, is that
like for all DMs or for you specifically? That's for me spec
I can't speak for all DMs. That's for me specifically. But considering
that that's the only measurement that matters is because it's
me.
I'm not someone else. So yeah, that's me specifically.
Okay. But like, have you thought about why they wouldn't? A like
aside aside from the obvious clout chasers because Oh, no, no,
no, no, no, no. This is before clout. Okay. This is before any
of that. These measurements are based off my entire career.
So 17.8%.
Okay. Well, have you thought about why that? Of course I have,
Naomi. Please. Yes, I have. I have augmented behaviors. I have
done experiments to determine why. I have tried to pick different
ethnicities. I've tried to do different gender counts. I've done
everything with that was within my power to experiment to experiment
and that number has remained
depressingly the same. So
that's the way it is. It could just be because it's me. No. Okay.
I I even invited blacks to my D and D. I hide everything. I don't
know why I yelled that. I shouldn't have yelled that. Uh jeez.
Okay. Well, right off of that moment, click the Tory Lane. Hate
that. Click the Tory Lane's link. You'll hear his verse is so
good. He is just so good. And then the end of it, the end of
it just me. Listen. Just listen.
I just want to point out that uh Cherry once asked me if I knew
this song and I listened and I was like no. She like she was like,
"No, you do know it." And then she played it for me and I was
like, "No." And she's like, "Wait until the hook." And then the
hook happened and I was like, "No, he still did not know the
There is not a single person who didn't know this song, who didn't
get so sick of this song, cuz not only did the the original get
played the out, then the remix got played the out. And I can't
believe he doesn't know this song." All right, play it. Play
it. Got her. I'm out here with somebody. She calling me daddy.
I'm somebody father. I got to go. When I go kiss it, I put my
lips on it like somebody b watered a diamond in a glacier. The
caught in a wallet. She put up the me, but nobody caught it.
She told me that she wasn't feeling my music. She told me it's
nobody harder and I'm with the gi. I need that for the freaky.
We are not buying no. You sell it on pastry. It's so much work
on my I had to go tell my to reach me all in my DM or follow
your BM. She play with the croski. We used toki. She used to
lie on my bed and go lie to your face and say I'm just a broki.
You knows me. You ain't believe it. You wanted to toast me. I
had extended as long as a ruler in case you was cooling it. It's
coming up. Lock the beta came back in the cing and she want to
[__] again. I want that tongue again. Stuck it so
deep that she cough up again. Five star [__] they
on the run again. Run again. Running in diamonds they illuminating
the way that I come again. I just put so many pennies on the
watch and I never got stunning. [__] little to what's
popping. Brand new whip just hopped in. Why? Why did he do that?
Why did he just go? Cuz he wins. He does nothing but win. This
guy's a winner. Hold on. Let's go.
Pull it back. Pull it back. He ruined it. Canada. Canada. I'm
going to start doing this. I'll just I'll get when we get people
on the stream, okay, and they're like talking back and forth.
We get like four people in here. I'll just show up at some point.
I'll be like I'll be right back. And then when I come back, I'll
just go Canada. Canada, let's go. Canada. Brand new whip. Just
let's go. I I swear to God, I've never seen a rapper There's
so many rappers who rep their city, rep their hood, rep their
gang. Not a goddamn rapper ever repped to Canada before and I
want to die cuz he's actually so gifted. The nerve of him. This
I don't know. I love to see it. I don't know why Cherry doesn't
love to see it. Canada represents Just pretend you're from Compton
or something. No.
Oh, speaking of being from Compton andor living that really tough
life growing up. Okay, back to Techone.
Oh, hold on. Wait. We will back to Techone in one second. uh
top Bronson going uh Drake
uh no Drake has literally adopted every other identity to run
from his Canadianism.
Okay, he's become Jamaican. He's he raps and sings in PWA and
then also starts just No, not Drake. Okay, back to techone.
Not Drake. Hold on. Not this one. Not this one. I want the other
one. Oh, Jesus Christ. Not this one
No. Nope. What are you looking for?
Music. This wasn't it. Nope. Drake will always be little wheelchair
Jimmy from Degrassi. Do you know that he used to complain to
the writers of Degrassi that it's hurting his rap career that
he's still in the wheelchair when he was acting? This was the
one we needed. Okay, continue on with Teto. We needed this song.
All right. Is it this song? Uh, it's
No, no, no. This is the one from the percentages video. Oh, okay.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Doesn't matter. only matters what you can prove.
And on the internet, the truth doesn't matter. It only matters
we can get people to believe. I think I think it's sickening
how little people go, hm, let me Google that. They go, well,
oh, also hold on. 28 minutes ago. 28 minutes ago.
We will check this out after the techone video. Okay, we will
check it out after the techone video. Bruce Rivers criminal lawyer
reacts. Yeah, we actually we need more time on the stream, guys.
We need you to dig deep for another hour on the stream. Okay,
I need you. I need you. 14 subs.
No, no, no, no, no, no. Um, uh,
seven, seven subs. Hassan said this and
I really want Hassan to eat my [__] So, I go ahead
and believe this. Well, Denim said this, and
she's at least a six out of 10. I've never seen a woman before,
so
what she said. Uh, why haven't they seen a woman?
Is it because you only show them anime weeb girls all the time?
Denims was a six of 10. Damn.
She's definitely more than that.
That's [__] up. I he Well, he really has to choose
here, right? Is she an attractive woman with pretty privilege
who's only successful because people jerk off to her, or is she
a six out of 10? Which one? And not just people that he jerks
off to. He watches her without his pants on. He's already self-reported
that. So, is he saying he wanks it to six out of tens?
That seems odd. The whole internet of 10 out of 10. To be fair,
his 10 out of 10 is a literal 10-year-old anime girl. So, unfortunate
tastes like honey and cinnamon, but only when they turn 18. Good
lord. That whole guy disgusting. What a guy. Like we are we are
in the day and age where
we have actual
super villains,
right? Actual super villains harassing people's real life, their
family, their children, their parents, their grandparents, their
dead relatives.
They're calling people criminals. They're giving them false allegations.
They're doing false accusations. And because people align with
them politically or are left-leaning, they say, "These are the
good guys." Holy, holy. I feel so bad for the children of today's
day and age because it's going to be a mess, guys. It's It's
only going to get worse. You got these Greek shows on Twitter
saying, "Yeah, they're 8 years old. Yeah, they're old enough
to chop their off and inject HRT." Yeah, go
What the Where did that come from? I don't know.
I don't I Well, hold on. Okay. Is he running a script? Yeah.
No, he is running a script. The reasons he's saying things like
this is obviously because techs watch how people apply this in
politics, right? How basically everybody in the Democrat side
can fall back from the the transposition and Republicans don't
go, "Oh, we won. We won. We don't have to talk about this anymore."
They'll just keep saying, "No, no, no. These people love cutting
their off of children." They want to cut off of children, right?
It doesn't matter that like they won. That issue is dead. They
won. Yeah. No more transing kids. Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter.
They're just going to keep talking about it forever. If he really
cared about the culture war, he would just he would grift all
the way and say they tried to cut my dick off. Yeah, that's why
this is what my looks like now cuz they tried to Never mind.
Just keep keep playing the video. I'm very glad my parents didn't
push me off a building because I believed it so hard. These are
lifealtering decisions that should not be made at 8 to 12 years
old. I also feel so bad for gay people because my god, there
is no one on this earth who makes gay people look worse than
gay people. What the Who are you? So you got What is happening,
dude?
This is He's calling He's looking for the self-hating gays, right?
The gays who are like, "I'm the only good gay." I don't know
what he's do. I literally don't know what he's doing. He He's
looking for the people who tell themselves they're not homophobic
while kind of being like low-key homophobic.
Like if I had never been on the internet, this would probably
work on me, okay? Cuz I'm like a touch homophobic, but I again
have the introspection, the ability to like self analyze and
realize that's wrong. You shouldn't do that, right? But when
gay guys kiss, I'm like, gross. Why? Why' you do that in public?
Gross. Keep it keep it to yourself. But I know that that's wrong.
So, I think that would work on me kind of, but
uh I think all PDA is gross. Yeah, I don't think
people do it. Yeah, that's mostly true.
Uh he's saying their representation is bad and they don't denounce
the bad actors so it makes them look bad. That applies to literally
everybody though. That literally applies to everyone. The CEO
of the Daily Wire a year and a half ago was in a Twitter space
talking about how much he watches Nick Fuentes's show and how
funny Nick is while being best friends with Ben Shapiro. Yeah.
Literally everybody does this. I just I actually can't understand
how he went from talking about all of these fake friends to
and I feel bad for gay people. We can't let the trans get the
of the six-year-olds anymore. Guys, you cannot you cannot cut
your own off at nine. You can't do it. Okay. Just cuz you believe
it real hard. Okay. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks.
Thank you. No sh just repeating most recent stream.
Like, is it just that if you do this? Yeah. Yeah. You have to
do if you sit outside like this, you have to make a video that
sounds like this. Like, you already know. You have to go this
way. Bass Pro Shop's hat. Do you think he's ever been fishing
in his life?
Uh, why does he have a Bass Pro Shops hat? Yeah, Project Atlas.
Nobody wants to be intellectually dishonest to one up one another.
That's like primarily what we try to look at here. This is just
embarrassing. No, he hasn't been fishing. Every every fishes
are you about to say everybody fishes? What do you mean? Is are
they by the water in Texas?
I have no idea where they are. Yeah, I got no idea. But I Yeah,
I just I don't know why the Hatfield performative. This guy streams
6 hours a six days a week. I don't I don't feel like he goes
fishing, but maybe he does. Hey, maybe I'm totally wrong. Walk
around naked with your out in front of the kids. What the Oh,
kink pride. Kink of Pride. Let's go. Pride on Coco Melon. Call
it a day.
Kids are being raised by this gay ass on the internet.
Believing everything they see on Fortnite and Minecraft Gaia
online. That's a dated reference. That probably dead. What happened
to Neopets, man? Didn't the take over Neopets? I have no idea.
I I feel like this right here is like it's like jump the shark.
It's like so obvious with like the the grifting talking points
that he's like never really cared to say before. It's like Jump
the Shark entirely. I don't It's so unbelievable. Uh anyone ever
play Habbo Hotel? I think so.
Yeah, I think I played that. I think I played that. I feel like
it took me a long time to understand what the pool closed due
to AIDS meant. I actually like just didn't go to that room. I
was way too
Jesus. Content creators getting pets for clout,
not even raising them. Cats way too young for that game. Did
you hear what he said? Content creators getting pets for clout,
not even raising them. Creators getting He is weaving so hard.
This is like some Donald Trumpes weave. Okay, there's no connection
between these topics whatsoever. He is just weaving all over
the place. man. Content creators getting pets for clout,
not even raising them, treating cats like furniture rather than
friends. It's just depressing, man.
It's rare seeing people treat each other like humans or even
creatures like, you know, they're friends. They treat them like
objects. It's disgusting. And the worst thing is everybody who's
trying to advocate for better treatment of each other, who are
trying to go, is that what Tee does? Techone advocates for better
treatment of each other.
Literally the only thing I know him for is saying he jerks off
to denims. You you stupid and frogging, you're fat. That's sorry.
And the assault claims against him. No, those are the things
I know him for. He's not going to imply like he's one of them.
He's going to say all the people that do call for it. Then he's
going to I guess say how much they're fake or they contribute
to it.
advocate for better treatment of each other who are trying to
go against the bad guys. Well, congratulations. They're the bad
guys. These people have no media literacy. Media literacy for
how they treat their cats. If you're right leaning, if you're
conservative, you're a Nazi. Jesus. Everybody's a Everybody's
a Everybody's a trans phobe. Everybody's a homophobe. Everybody's
in your genealogy. Maybe everybody's a manipulator. Just cuz
you have a disagreement of opinions.
Good job.
Getting eaten alive by the mosquitoes out here. By the way, feel
like I have a lot of free. You literally could pause the recording
and get bug spray. You could I'm free from all the shackles that
used to bind me. Except the mosquitoes.
Wait, wait, wait. Sorry. I was muted. Shut up. Hold on. Wait.
Did that go through? I don't know if that went through. How long
has my mic been muted for? Uh, that whole time. And then you
just played the music. Okay. Well, I said some stuff and now
I'm back. Just like that. Two two second. Okay, just two seconds.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I was like, "Okay,
this guy needs to shut up." But because I need to play the music.
Feel like I have a lot of freedom. I'm free from all the shackles
that used to bind me.
Being a part of
But it was so good getting out of it as well. It was I hate when
my actions affect others, you know, cuz there are some people
who are weaker, and it's fine to be weak, who can't handle it,
and I'm glad I don't have to worry about them anymore. I know
you're seeing me call out a lot of uh content creators, but I
hope you guys understand the difference between my channel, and
I want you, if you're here, I want you to leave a comment based
off this. I want you to really understand the difference
between my channel
and a normal drama channel
because people will call out
because of views and clicks. Don't get me wrong, do I want more
views? Sure. Why does not want to know why? Because I know it
drives the haters crazy.
But I'm not calling these people out. It's my job. I'm doing
it because if you look at the people who I'm calling out, they're
doing horrific ass horrific things. Look at my track record of
the people I've called. Hey, like Okay, hold on. We'll watch
making a fake document to take down his enemies and his friends.
do I need to say more? Denims, do I need to say more? Yeah, I
actually need you to continue on with these people. The Hassan
one's easy if he says the terrorist not just terrorist propaganda.
That's so lazy. Say what you actually did. But uh Denims,
what is like the worst thing Denims did? Is it Is it just stealing
the content from Is it like saying I want to take views from
Ethan Klein and then rereaming? Is that the worst thing? No,
literally all of these men cannot stand that she sits there with
her cleavage and laughs at them and just doesn't care. She will
sit there with a smile laughing and saying just wrong things
and still so happy. And that just that actually eats them alive.
true. Calling him a That is why he says denims. Wait, so calling
him a What was that actually from Denims? I think she said alleged,
right? She said alleged for one of the things. I'm trying to
remember exactly how she implied he was. We went through this
whole evidence thing and I can't remember what she said that
was so bad. Well, he continuously uses a clip where the comment
that uh Denims is replying to never says that she called him
a and he just like he like creates a narrative for what is happening
in that clip that she never said. Why would he just clip the
part where she says, right? Yeah. she's like believing the allegations
or she's believing these women and he just reiterate or he just
uh explains to people what's happening in this clip is Denims
is calling me a and saying that I can't sue her for it and it's
like okay where is that it's not in the message that she brought
pulled up and is reading it's not in anything that she says like
are you good right yes right cuz that's what it is is uh no what
is it he he can sue me then cuz truth is an absolute defense
from defamation or whatever And I believe the allegations are
some like that's how which he says. So yeah, it's I can see how
he can paint it that way. Interesting.
If there is uh clips of Denim saying that he's a and he blah
blah blah. Okay. Why wouldn't you just use those clips? That
confuses out of me. That's true. Uh what was I going to say here?
Call I think probably stealing content like the uh like the Alazer
thing's pretty bad. I think stating that you want to take views
or that you're happy you took views away from Ethan Klein and
like rereaming while he's streaming his big content piece. I
think she tried to add commentary so it gets it by a little bit.
I think the for me the stated intent to like take views away
does uh like morally sound you like a total piece of but I think
that's far worse than anything she said about techone. I'm pretty
sure. I'm pretty sure. Not 100% sure though.
Yeah. Anyway, do I need to say more? Mike from EA. Do I need
to say more? You've all heard this a thousand times. The horrific
people who are accusing people of crimes, going after people's
dead relatives. Wait. Oh, he didn't even say Casey Tron going
after people's dead relatives. He left Casey Tron out, but then
he he kind of included her with that one cuz she always says
that Asmin Gold his mom, which is up and I I don't like that
she says that. That's not my understanding of what she says.
What do you think? Wasn't Isn't that Isn't that direct clip hold?
Can you pause the music? So real isn't the the clip that's continuously
referenced. That's when Casey says um
that Asthma Gold has so much money. How does he let his mom live
like that? I don't even have as much as he does. And I uh put
my dad in better conditions than he does his mom. Like you're
kind of a piece of for letting your mom live like that given
how much like money and resources you have. Cuz Asmin would like
I'm sorry. It's just the idea that you have a sick parent and
you don't do anything to like clean your house and stuff.
It probably breeds even more illness and disease. It's not saying
like you killed your mom. It's like you have the means to I don't
know for her to have better living conditions. And yeah, she
liked a tweet that said, "Thankfully XQC's lifestyle hasn't led
indirectly to the death of one of his parents. So he has at least
that going for him over Asmin at least." She liked that tweet
that said that. I see. I see. Isn't that the same? Yes. Well,
no, but she has literally said the this is like um
you're saying a a tweet. I've seen her explain this exact same
thing. Okay, I'll find I'll find the clip. No, I still think
like I think if you say about like you being responsible for
your for your parent dying, even if that's true, I feel like
you gain the right to dislike that person. Yeah, Asma Gold can
dislike her. That's talking, right? And I because I genuinely
believe that that hoarding lifestyle, it's not just um
his his problem, it probably is also his mom's problem. It like
the idea that he feels comfortable that way, his mom could feel
comfortable that way, too. And how do you get like one person
to be more motivated to change things for another? I don't know.
Asmin literally didn't want to clean his house on his own until
he lost a debate to Hassan. So
really, we should blame Hassan for not debating Asmin Gold like
years ago or something. Actually, Hassan's fault. Fixed it. Wow.
True. Hassan Asmin Gold's mom. Godamn. Godamn.
Okay, I got it. I got it. Running is about misinformation
to blind the mats. Oh, I need I need music back. I need music
back. getting one of his friends
to near fatal levels of alcohol poison, ruining his entire life
and then skirting all accountability and not lending out a hand
to help a guy who is the sole one of the sole reasons why he's
still successful in the space. I mean, Jesus Christ. People always
say with friends like Lwig, wait, wait, wait, wait. Who did who
did Lewig do that to? Hold on. guy who is the one of all accountability
and not lending out a hand to help a guy who is the so one of
the sole reasons why he's still successful in the space. Is he
saying mango? There's no way he's saying mango here is one of
the reasons Lewig's still successful. Is he?
I don't even know what that means cuz he said he threw Mango
under the bus and then he's like wouldn't hold a hand to help
a guy who's one of the main reasons. Is that is that someone
else? I I don't know. I'm confused. I mean is [__]
right. People always say with friends like Lwig, who needs enemies,
bro? That's everybody. So many people are like that. I didn't
even like Mango. I didn't even know the guy. But you see these
parties, you see everybody having fun. Mango was in a house with
so many people, 80 other streamers, and not a single one of them
was a friend.
Anybody
in that house should have seen that he wased up and he needed
to be taken out. They could have said something. They could have
done something. They did nothing. They did nothing. And yeah,
he's Didn't this guy live in the house where all these like this
guy lived right next to Miskf while Msk like ran every small
streamer in Austin through the same
I I just have to I have to speak more carefully. Jesus Christ.
Sorry. I uh I feel like this guy was a part of some stuff, part
of an organization. Part of like some that was happening down
there in Austin. It's a little weird. People got weird thoughts
and weird stories about OTK and the house parties they throw.
I feel like this guy was around it. When did he stand up and
go, "No, no, no, no. Hey, hey, this is wrong, guys." I feel like
that's difficult to do, especially in streamer situations.
I I'm trying to think of a time TeeOne did that. Teone was a
part of these groups. Whereas he stood up and said, "This is
all wrong." Unless it was Unless it was after he got kicked out
of these groups. after you got nexted by these groups. Like I'm
fine with him calling it out, but I I don't like him just trying
to like make it about all the people. You could or, you know,
take some accountability yourself, that kind of thing. I don't
know. Pardoned. Weird. But my god, would it have somebody to
do anything? I'm glad we have people like Sensitive Society and
more Pegasus.
piece of calling me a Genchin player. Oh, you
piece of [__] Uh, dude, I do actually kind of want
to see the sensitive society video now. We are six subs. Six
subs. Six subs. Also, guys, I think Kit Chat has been in and
out all night. So, unfortunately,
it's the chat we got. Okay, it's the chat we got. It's kind of
struggling. It is what it is. All right. It is what it is. to
call out the bad actors, but they get labeled as slop tubers
because, man, they really hate when people talk about the truth,
don't they? They really hate it. They hate it, bro. The world
hates the truth. They hate it. Have I been wrong about some things?
Absolutely.
But I always try my best. It's a big bug. I always try my best
to be as
as honest, as truthful as I possibly can. I might have messed
up. I might have spoke on some things in the past where I didn't
have the full context.
I mean, [__] I don't even know what my own dad did
until recently. I had to find out about that from Assassan.
Although, again, he greatly exaggerated it.
Greatly exaggerated. Did he? I think he just How How badly did
he exaggerate it? Can we see the Hassan Techone clips
I do want to see the his exaggerate at all father and he can't
keep saying that his ex Pinky literally said that his dad was
uh commenting on those
on the convictions or whatever around her saying that those women
lied. He she did say that. I'm trying to find Hold on. This is
him crying.
Can I get the
goes off on techone by discussing his father
clip in here or what? That is the craziest. I mean, it's not
even a milkshake style situation cuz it's like like it for a
milkshake to occur like this needs to be a beloved figure and
not a bald himself, right?
What was hilarious about this? Wait, what was it?
Like this needs to be a beloved figure and not a bald himself,
A little bit. What's hilarious about the situation is like I
didn't know anything about his dad
you know literally where is this reference you posted come in
with receipts posted bro so where did this reference happen do
you think this person will change their perspective about this
guy Hawkeye Impact third got to be the best game Australia
yeah like what why would you invite people looking for this information
it's I just want the epigenetic comment okay investigated by
myself and there's a person with the same name rank as similar
age to tech's dad and he was indeed found guilty of 14 counts
harassment. It definitely wasn't his dad. His dad served in the
late 80s, the early 90s. Anything after that, he probably wasn't
active and was a reserve. Plus, I know people like Casey.
It was his dad though, right? He literally It was
Hold on. This is This is the line right here. Okay. Okay. Is
Iron Mike, which was also the nickname explicitly referenced
in the trial of Michael Robertson. It's pretty. So, they they
literally use the same nickname and he calls his dad Iron Mike.
They used it in the in the court case. Cherry Iron Mike Y was
grabby as sorry. What were you going to say?
No, it's like they had accounts like already trying to offiscate
pretend like it's not that person just like flat out lie. Man,
I Yeah,
it's so weird how like chatters will do that. Like chatters will
just like make things up
or or they'll just take like other lies and they'll just like
propagate. Like if Teon had told them at any point like I don't
know if that's true. All of these people go, "Wait, wait, wait.
That's probably not true." Like, they'll just they'll extend
it. It's weird. Yeah. I don't know. I think I think they do it
because they believe the person,
so they just wanted to like their instinct is this guy has to
lie for him. Yeah. Yeah.
Obviously, his father-in-law is not a surprise considering the
history of abuse that runs in the family. Like this
has, I guess, epigenetic memories of He had to do it, you know?
He just couldn't he could talk. I knew I knew Hassan wouldn't
be. Okay. I knew Hassan would just say a crazy with no um with
nothing else going on. I knew I knew he would do it. Okay. Hassan
isn't a He'll blow things out of proportion. He'll be hyperbolic.
Let's go.
He's like just the right amount of informed leftist to be able
to make that joke and not sound like a like Arcadum. It's very
funny. Skumid, I can see how pressed you are. It's okay. Hassan
can't hurt you here. You'll be safe. Hassan is even more hyperbolic.
Let us slaves go. I don't know what you're talking about, but
Hassan Hassan is bad. Isan is really bad. Okay.
All right. All right. Where are we going?
Back to this. Okay. We got to finish this vid. Holy moly. 24
minutes. But I'm glad I'm in this era where some content right
here. I've broken the illusion of the internet.
And now I've approached everything with skepticism.
$5. What?
Yo, 25 bucks from Anonymous. We have 30.
That's 30 30 35
One sub. We are one sub away from another hour on the stream,
guys. One sub. One sub. What is this background music? It's meant
to be appropriately dramatic for Tee and the drama that he is
spinning for us over here. Okay, Teone is being very self victimizing.
Wait, was it actually one sub? Yeah, cuz we need six subs. And
then we got $25, which is five subs. And then we got five subs.
And then we got five subs anyway.
So now we need two more subs. Five, two, No, four more. But we
do have another
Face. Wait, are you actually calculating something? I was just
talking. I thought it was off. Wait, I am actually calculating
things. What are you talking about? Oh, I was just making up.
Damn. Crazy. That stoicism [__] Jesus. Holy. That
thing is huge. That's the biggest bug I've ever seen in my whole
life.
What the is that? Jesus. Bug the size of a bird. That thing going
to pick me up and fly away. You going to bring me back to the
nest. Going to bring me back to Roach Ranch.
There's a lot of things I wanted to say. Yeah, I probably
I appreciate you guys.
I really do.
Okay, I woke up this morning and I didn't feel too good, so I
took the day off. And I also really wanted to spend the day with
my girlfriend and my dog. I'll be real. I'm trying very hard
to spend time with the people and the things that I care about
the most in this world. I probably could have streamed, but I
just I really wanted to chill with my uh girl and my dog. Someone
is dating. spend about an hour and a half a day building a
mono green
uh called shufus.
What did you think I was taking bets on the over under 6 months?
Yeah. I don't know why it's an accusation or a case or
It just hit me after after hearing Hassan talking about his epigenetics.
Like finding out that it's literally in this guy's DNA to rap
and then still like no I'll date you. It's crazy. Yeah, like
the biggest I can fix him type. I mean, realistically,
even if worse comes to worse, he's not doing that much damage.
That's just that's just facts. Okay, that's actually just facts.
Like, listen, if this was No, I can't. I can't. I literally can't
deck for my girl.
$500. Jesus. But I love playing Magic the Gathering is so good.
Wait, Magic the Gathering is so good. Uhoh. But I do feel very
bad for a lot of people who watch
my videos. Not because my videos are that bad. And they are bad.
Not that reason, but the world is not it's not easy. It's not.
I know a lot of you who watch me, who watch content creators
in general, unemployed,
working minimum wage jobs, and they probably live life they don't
enjoy. That's not true. Everybody who watches this stream is
not working a minimum wage job. They're gainfully employed. They've
got long running careers and they all donate very much and I
appreciate all of them. Okay, that's every single person. All
of you guys have a lot of money to give to streamers, mostly
to me, but sometimes to Cherry on her Twitch. Okay.
Okay. All right, we're continuing. Let me pull up my Twitch.
See who showed love.
How [__] up would it be if I've been getting Twitch
subs?
That would be up. What is your job? I don't know what your job
is, sir. I'm a need. Well, that's unfortunate. Hopefully, you
still have money to donate.
Dolce belly
dolce bellum inertise.
You're here all the time, so I do appreciate it. Okay. I do very
much appreciate you. Thank you very much. Cherry seems like the
type of person that that probably believed everything Amber Heard
ever said about Johnny Depp. It is adorable that you think that
I watched any of that trial. Uh, and I believed in Johnny Depp
the whole time because I like Pirates of the Caribbean. I was
like, he didn't do it. I dude Jack Sparrow would never. I saw
Pirates of the Caribbean. That's how I knew he did it.
No, he didn't do anything crazy. She pooped on his bed. Okay,
that's pretty that's pretty unhinged. That just sounds like a
gone wrong. No, no, no.
It was like a That sounds like a fetish that he regretted. You
know when guys let a girl peg them and they're like, "Nope, don't
tell people about that." No, he asked for it and now he regrets
it. I don't know what that's like. That's That is insane. That
is crazy. I heard it's a thing I hear about. I don't know. Mhm.
Okay. And I think about it every day. I think about help
thinks about it every single day. Do you think Teone is is selfless
enough to just like use a strap on anyway,
help a girl out? like he's not getting much done himself. I'm
I got to stop. I got to stop. I got to stop. They probably live
life they don't enjoy. That's rude. That's very rude. And they
use these videos as an escape. And I think about dancing on this
guy's grave. I think about how hard you guys have it. I think
about how difficult the world is. Think about [__]
$400,000 a month for just like pushing pedto games to people.
I just think about how hard you guys have it. Okay. As I'm sitting
here streaming, I just think about how hard, how miserable your
lives are. What
disasters of human beings you all are, okay? You guys are all
losers. I can't imagine you amounting to anything in life. You
have to come watch me because I'm awesome and you guys suck and
this is the your only escape. I am your escape. You just pretend
to be me. I Okay, you guys
[__] me up. I'm a pretty emotional guy. I'm not going
to lie. And I know it I know it's not good to be an emotional
guy on the content page, but uh I developed empathy at 3 years
old. That just makes me think of who's the one who just got empathy
recently. Uh Idubbbz, right? That's one. Why is everybody just
like letting us know at what point in their life they discovered
empathy? Um and what does he mean at three? I don't know. I I
don't want to Oh, wait. Is that when he got Never mind. Yeah,
I know. I know. I don't want to make that joke. I don't want
to make that joke. That joke is
I just got the joke. I developed empathy at 3 years old. I just
hope everybody watching this video. How do you have this reaction
then? I'm sorry. You don't if it happened when you were three.
You actually don't have a memory of it. That's not true. I have
a memory of being three. Well, it's like a memory of a memory.
But I did I did actually remember when I was like three at some
point.
Yeah. Yep. Time. You got to fight. You can't give up. You can't
let these people hurt you. You can't let him get to you. I remember
it cuz I had uh Michelangelo from the Ninja Turtles on my birthday
cake when I was three. Yep. That's how I remember it. You can't
let him slow you down. Where? That's a is that by the way that
is my memory from when I was three. It was my third birthday
and it's just Michelangelo. I remember the pose. Okay. On the
birthday cake. Nunchucks going going hard windmilling around.
Friend that stabbed you in the back. Okay. Well, when my little
brother was three, I dropped him on his head on the metal like
foot thingy of my bunk bed and he doesn't remember that.
So, even if something like really hurts you, I just I don't think
it really stays with you. Oh, you're saying like so Tech wouldn't
remember. I got you. I got you. I know all about that. But I'd
uh question for you guys to name a single person who I've ever
stabbed in the back. I don't do that. Her brother was brain damaged
and currently lives in a wheelchair, by the way. So, he doesn't
really speak or say anything. I just But he also doesn't remember
it. So, it's fine, guys. It's fine. He lives a very full life.
Okay.
I even go so far as to defend my enemies. There's some people
currently who I go in on, they're like, I wonder why he says
this even though that person did this. I could ruin these people's
lives. How are you going to be such an as with the wonderful
birds chirping behind you? Like it's such a cheery atmosphere
somewhere just destroying people's lives. I'll ruin these people's
lives. He's a special guy. Okay. He's just a very special guy.
Sometimes it's just trying I'm just trying to let go. And maybe
I'm making a mistake. Maybe I shouldn't keep hold these people
accountable. I don't know. I hope you guys
can continue to fight every day and keep your head up high and
know that
hard work is how you're going to find a place of salvation.
It's how you're going to find your Vinland Saga. Great anime
by the way you should watch. Nope. And where you will find your
peace
because you cannot achieve anything worth attaining
or anything covetous in this world without hard work. Oh, a bagel
and coffee. you just showed up. You missed the start of the video
where his opening line was just with that exact thing. What a
normal thing to say when you're having a great life. He showed
up for the video and he's like, I just want you guys to know
that my mental health is so good right now. I am doing so well
in life.
I forgot about
I'm not even I'm not even kidding. That might be literally the
first thing he says. Hold on. Let me go Let me go back. Let me
grab a time stamp. Go back to like the very very very beginning.
What's up, guys? I know
my a day off. Try to think. I think he says he does like some
basic setup. He might even go into like the I can't remember
when he
uh once every six days or so. And the sound quality is probably
pretty the lawn mower guy in the background that that
started. By the way, I I could end the recording and just say
ah I'll wait till he's done. But I already know these videos
that I make don't really matter anyways. I don't really think
anybody cares
any others.
AC unit in the night. He's been a very good boy. Sophia, my roommates
don't wake up till the crack of noon. Yeah. I just kind of wanted
to talk about some thoughts that I've been having. There we go.
And uh I I would like to preface this saying like I'm in a very
good mental space right now. I'm very good mentally. I'm honestly
pretty happy, but I'm just kind of disgusted. Just need to preface
this with saying I'm uh in a good mental space. Okay. I'm honestly
very mentally happy. Now, let me rant about everybody I hate
for a little while. Let's go. Yeah, cuz unfortunat he's he's
not in a mental space. Like he's not singularly in one head space.
His is scattered throughout the globe right now. He's got one
head into all of the friends he never made. All of the friends
who left him, all of the friends, he actually doesn't even need
them to talk to him. Like he's fine. He doesn't need people to
keep up with him. And also, I feel bad for the gays. And how
could they convince kids to cut their off? And the son outed
my dad as a to me. I never knew. Like his is fried and then that
bug is so big. I don't know. Yeah, bug's huge. Massive.
So, keep that [__] up. I know it's hard right now,
but you got to keep pushing. You do. Keep it pushing. You do.
And I know that may sound corny.
That same advice from one of my favorite content creators. His
name is Etica.
Who is that?
guy themselves.
There's Etica and Rentful and streamers will just randomly use
them for like to make a point out of nowhere
for no [__] reason. No, that they killed themselves.
No, but I'm saying do you you obviously invoke those people to
signal out that you're No, I think you invoke them to say like
this stuff's hard and that's why like we should be nicer to each
other. And I don't think it's to say you're I think it's to say
like people are I think so. I think so. Yesterday was Reckful's
5y year anniversary. No, today is yet Reckful's 5y year anniversary.
July 2nd. Not July 1st, but July 2nd. At least that's what Google
says. And that's I think what Kelly said, too. So yeah, Kelly
came in to clear that up, too. Yeah. Yep. Said some pretty motivational
about myself or about himself.
Uh motivational about uh his life and how things are hard. And
uh that gave me the strength to keep fighting.
And
you know, he didn't have that same strength. But, uh, I do every
now and then try to talk about some of the morals, some of the
values, some of the content that some of my favorite creators,
some of my favorite singers, Chris.
Yeah. Uh, has he mentioned any content or literally anything
that Etica has actually said? Okay. He's like, "Yeah, I I sometimes
think about how I want to kill myself. I'm strong enough where
Etica wasn't." And I just want to mention like some of the creators
that I really enjoy and like what the messages were and what
the content was. Literally has mentioned zero content value.
Some of the content that some of my favorite creators, some of
my favorite singers, Chris Cornell, Reckful, Etica. Oh, hey,
there's We're two for two. Let's go. Breach. Because I don't
believe you've truly died until people forget about you.
Man, to those people, they meant so much to me. This guy is just
so unbelievably
cringe. It's so seems really It's just so insanely cringe to
do this. Like, if I if I kill myself and I'm able to go through
with it and myself, do not sit there and be like, "Well, you're
not actually done cuz I'm going to still think about you and
keep you alive." Yeah. I remember that time Cherry told me that
a guy she dated brought rubber duck to her house and she
until that story dies. Definitely definitely don't keep me alive
on that story. We will she Nobody can die. Nobody Cherry will
live forever because I'll never forget about the rubber and I
am I will be immortal at some point. So
rubber duck forever rubber forever.
Jeez. I uh don't really want to let their memory die. A lot of
the people who I looked up to the most in this world have committed
to There's hope. There's hope for all of us. There's hope these
videos will stop. No, that's
I'm sorry. That is actually just like why? Oh god. I don't know
why. I just want to play this resolution God. I just I feel like
that's appropriate here for no particular reason. What did he
just say? Let's roll it back. don't really want to let their
memory die.
A lot of the people who I looked up to the most in this world
have committed and I think a lot of the people that I've looked
up to most in the world
committed this is bordering on ideiation.
No, this is significantly more funny than somebody actually ideiating
cuz I would feel bad for somebody expressing ideiation
most of the time. In this case, not this fellow right now. Okay,
this guy is up.
I think this is like satirical ideation though. Yeah. Like I
don't think he's ever once actually considered harming himself
in any way. I don't think so. He's too much of a narcissist.
Yeah. I don't think I don't think he's ever thought about it.
I think that's so sad because
some of the most beautiful people on this earth. We say that
until he offs himself and then they clip this moment and say
it and like don't let us live it down.
Yeah. Be okay being one of the 13 reasons.
It will not be my fault. It's not my fault Hassan revealed his
genetic
ep whatever epigenetic memories of epigenetic memories of epigenetic
memories of Also speaking of queen viewers welcome queen with
the with the raid on kick. Thank you very much. Appreciate it.
Speaking of epigenetic epigenetic memories of Yes.
God was such a long video. I don't we I think we turned this
into like four hours of content. This was just like all over
the place. Yeah, we won't be sued. Okay, we won't be sued for
this. This is absolutely transformative. Boy, oh boy. You know,
the brightest stars burn out the quickest.
That is up. I wish I could have met him. I wish I could have
said something to him. I'm soed up. I think Well, maybe if I
knew him that wouldn't have happened. Yeah, that's there's a
word for that. It starts with an N.
Don't start typing. Don't start trying to type it in chat because
you will fail and then I'll have to time you out. Okay, now it
sucks because Reckful passed before I ever got a chance to meet
him, even though we would have lived in the same town. And uh
trust me, I get a Austin scene right now. Didn't know Reckful.
Didn't know Reckful. He didn't know Etica. No, he's known none
of these people that died. Stop it. That's even That's actually
worse.
It is worse. Yes. He's literally saying I didn't know them. And
then he was like, "Somehow I think that if I did know them, I
could have stopped them from doing it." But he said he wased
up. Yes. He's admitting he's a narcissist. Yes. I always I felt
so um I didn't know what the kind way to go about it was, but
I think it was somebody that dated Reckful that told me that
I reminded them of him. And I just couldn't understand if it's
because I had BPD or because I was like mentally ill on the internet.
I was just like like I really liked her and I just didn't want
to say anything off. But to like I don't know feel some sort
of way about that person is just is weird to me. Yeah. Like when
you don't know them at all. Yeah. You don't know them and the
only thing you know is that they killed themselves. Like Well,
I will say
I was in a ventrillo call with him once like a decade ago. So
I know him way better than Tech does and I would feel incredibly
weird expressing any of these thoughts. Yeah. Yeah. I do think
that that's a that's a off thing. Yeah. It's like one of those
feelings. Okay. So for me, when the girlfriend said that to me,
it's like when somebody tells you, "Oh, you remind me of my daughter
that passed away several years ago." Like, you don't want to
do anything to upset them. Hopefully, it's a good memory that
they're invoking, and you get that they're going to see their
daughter every time they they like look at you or something.
That's how that felt. Oh, sorry, that was like off topic. No,
I Dude, I've I've never had that, but I do know some people who
have had that, and it's like uh incredibly awkward to Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, and then I mean it's awkward because it's like maybe I have
had that happen because I want to say the first thought was like
oh my god like I didn't even I wasn't even mad because I was
like I couldn't believe like if my mom had to deal with this.
I would hope somebody else would be nice if like my mom was dealing
with it is like what I think fair. I think yeah I just be I would
want somebody to be nice to them. So I'm like nice
but I don't think I've ever had it. It's like maybe a grocery
store or something. Not in like a longterm I couldn't imagine
it's some place you have to go back to. That'd be crazy. Would
you just find a new place to go? I feel like you might. I mean,
it depends.
Not really sure. Some people don't mind. Maybe feel more empathy
for the person. I just love the Death Note soundtrack playing
in the background now. God,
make anybody crazy. I don't know. It's just up thoughts I have
sometime. I can't tell you how how nice it is and how life-changing
it is to have one good friend that always has your back. But
in a space paraded by some of the fakest on this earth.
Sometimes this sometimes this field just disgusts me.
Some people got no way you should talk someone adequately.
So they'll just make up because the moment you get enough people
to believe it, well now it's the truth. Yeah. I want to remind
you guys that the best revenge to the people who've wronged you
is to live a good life. So do that. Find that. Find happiness.
Push through all the find your happiness.
And that will destroy everybody who's attempted to destroy you.
I'm probably rambling at this point, but I didn't get to stream
today, so I kind of just wanted to yiate
the subs and the channel. Make sure to follow me over on kick.
Probably still not going to stream on Twitch. We'll see what
happens when I get unbanned.
Love you guys. Take care of yourself.
God bless you. Leave a comment if you don't mind on this video.
Just tell me how you are. I'd love to hear about it. I'm going to
be scrolling through these comments for the next 24 hours. So,
if you're here, feel free to do that. And uh yeah, that's it.
And that's why I don't play Among Us. And that's why I don't
play Among Us. God damn, what a guy.
Yeah, we were playing the music, guys. If you didn't know, if
you came in late, uh it was just the Arcade bit. Okay, Tech did
his own little Arcadum video. Talked about how he can't maintain
friends cuz everybody's too quite obsessed in the space.
Very goofy stuff. Okay. Very, very goofy stuff.
All right. Where I might Where was I going to go next? Cuz I
I'm trying to think now. I kind of want to watch the sensitive
society video on denims and just see. It just feels like everybody's
phoning in the laziest videos and farming the freest. Oh, no,
no, no, no, no, no. Bruce Rivers. Hi, this is Right. Bruce Rivers.
That's what I wanted to do. Diddy verdict. Okay. Now, is he gonna
Is he gonna explain the same thing? Is it just going to be the
partial verdict, Cherry? Do we even need to do this? I think
we do cuz it's mostly just going to be explaining how it's going
to be the partial verdict stuff again, right? Yeah, the partial
verdict and all that can get thrown out if they change their
mind when they do decide on the uh on the one charge, they can
they can flip all all the other choices that they had previously
made. They've made choices on all curses except the Rico charge.
The Ricocharge they're still kind of like hesitant to go in on,
but I think we believe they will say there. They're not unanimous
on it yet. And so they're unanimous on four out of the five.
Um but that doesn't mean that after the they've come to a decision
on the fifth one that people can't go back and change their other
unanimous ones. Nothing is locked in until they're all submitted.
So, they could be uh undecided on the one charge and have decided
that all of the other four are guilty and then some explains
to them, hey, all of my life is in danger and my family um is
going to die if we don't all vote not guilty and everybody just
decides to change the entire the entire
What's up, Goon? What's up? How's it going? Do you uh pretty
good? Did you check out that techone video? Which one?
Today is what is it? Not this one. Sad go back. N I We're about
to We might watch the Sensitive Society video. Uh this one. Streamers
disgust me. He did an Asenold video outside video just ranting
on camera. Crying about Hassan being mean to him. I'm guessing
crying about that was part of it. Crying about um people advocating
for trans kids to get their cut off at like nine. He did like
every single grifting thing possible. It was like an actually
comical jumping the shark version.
And he said he feels bad for gay people because nobody makes
gay people look worse than other gay people and that's got to
be really hard for them. Yeah, I feel really bad for gay people
cuz nobody makes gay people look worse than gay people. Was a
quote. Um
oh man, of particular interest. Let's just go to the uh he started
invoking
he started invoking Etekica and Reckful and Chris Cornell.
Okay. I didn't find out until the end that he has never met any
of them. Yeah, he's not he's not met any of them. Hold on. Let's
uh because I don't believe you here. Hold on. I do every now
and then try to talk about some of the morals, some of the values,
some of the content,
some of my favorite creators, some of my favorite singers. Chris
Cornell, Reckful, Etekica,
Breach, because I don't believe you've truly died until people
forget about you.
And to those people, they meant so much to me. God, I uh don't
really want to let their memory die. A lot of the people who
I looked up to the most in this world have committed. That's
a promising outlook. Let's go. That's what I said. We have hope.
We have hope.
And I think that's so sad because
some of the most beautiful people on this
You know, the brightest stars burn out the quickest.
Okay, so not you then. That'sed up. I wish I could have met him.
I wish I could have said something to him. I'm soed up. I think
Well, maybe if I knew him that wouldn't have happened, dude.
It's crazy.
It was like a It wasn't quite at this level the whole time, but
it's it operates close to that a lot of this whole video. This
guy is such a loser, man. It's actually so crazy. It all pairs
up so much better knowing like the start of this video is him
saying how
uh really all he wants to do is like help streamers out and help
it so that they like make it and
like none of them are mean. He means he's like a kind of like
almost like a a streaming groomer. That that's what he means.
I compared it to MLM.
Like here he is selling this idea of like being a streamer to
like a bunch of people implying like this is going to be your
freedom. You're going to make it. And he really has like one
out of 30 people that he quote unquote helps like remains a streamer.
He holds over their head for the rest of their life. They don't
even make maybe like 2% of what he makes, right? They're just
like they're hanging on to it cuz they just like being his friend
or something like that. I think all of the successful people
around him aren't successful because of him. He's disgusting.
He looks disgusting wearing that vest. It's so gross, man. Look
at this guy. He's disgusting to look at. I need somebody to like
let me know. American physiology is super all the time. I'm not
going to lie. Yeah, he has such a big guy, but he's got like
actually way more narrow shoulders than I thought. Like he seems
like it might be his head. It might just be that his head is
so massive that it looks like his shoulders are narrow cuz when
he sits the other way, it doesn't look like his shoulders are
narrow. Maybe he also might be hunched forward a little bit.
I'm not sure. Hold on. This is Does anyone know? Does he have
streamers under him? Has he like brought up smaller streamers
or something?
No, he does rate a lot of streamers though, I believe. Which,
by the way, Techone, wherever you want to rate over here on kick,
I would appreciate it. Just saying. Just saying. Just saying.
No, we're not. Nobody on the stream will ever call you if you
raid tag. That's because we will say alleged assaulter. Okay.
Exactly. Alleged assaulter and abuser. Exactly. Yes. Yes.
The father convicted of 14 counts of harassment and assault.
Iron Mike.
That double played. It's fine.
It's fine. He raised a lot of people for me.
I'm with Hassan. I it's in your you are gonna I actually think
that you're gonna
just because you're aware that it's in your DNA to doesn't mean
you can stop it and I think it'll happen within the next 10 years.
That that one song clip I'm doing the impression of the woman
on the view has just been stuck in my head for like the last
3 days. What clip?
Oh, where is it? Who saw it about it? I can't remember who it
was relevant. It was irrelevant.
Oh, god damn it.
Somebody link me the clip. gay without Rey's reaction. It's on
Rey's Twitter. It's on Rey's Twitter. It's on Rey's Twitter.
He doesn't have his reactions. Tweet. Okay, guys. Go like and
follow Rey's Twitter.
This guy.
I'm I'm good. I'm not trying to start fights right now.
Anti-semitism. Let's go. The United States is nothing. Oh, did
she think it was Did he think it was anti-semitic? I didn't give
the impression. It wasn't anti-semitic. It was
dead. Yeah. Like if I step foot wearing this out,
I can't have my hair showing. I can't wear a skirt. I can't have
my
I literally Yeah. I can't wear my skirt in Theron. I can't eat
Kooby day.
Whoopi. Don't you understand? I can't wear bikini to the beach.
Whoopi. So obviously
they all need to die. We need to kill them. I can't wear my skirt
to beach and eat Kooby day. Said it was up to the What a guy.
What a guy. [__] What was a guy? Oh, we had to pull
this one up as well. Hold on. There's a couple good a couple
a few other good moments here. Techone opens this like when he
finally starts talking. He's like, I just want to talk about
a few things. And then he gives us like totally unasked for information
that makes me think he's not doing well. Wait, no, no, no. Yeah.
Please, please play the Arcana music
while we listen to it. Oh, okay. Well, I can. Hold on. Do I have
it here? I don't have it. Hi, this is Bruce Rivers. Uh, you know,
this just one second. It just hits different. Assan such a hypocrite.
So, preface this saying like I'm in a very good mental space
right now. I'm very good mentally. I'm honestly pretty happy,
but I'm just kind of disgusted
with the bigger I get, the more successful I get.
I feel that. I I feel that. Okay. Uh but hold on. I had this
Shimu tweet. You're saying Yeah. Yeah. Just generally when he's
when I think about how successful he gets and as he gets more
successful, the more he just like more and more disgusted and
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. Wasn't
tits. No, hold on. Looking for
uh when he was like, "This is why I watch VTubers." Oh, this
one right here. I I had to go find it. Yeah.
Okay. Watchers are cute and funny and I give up. Yeah. No, no,
no, no, no. Watch what he says. Wait, Rev is like this. Trying
to think of like male YouTubers that are a YouTuber of a little
girl. That doesn't count. Oh, hold on. Buy into that. But to
be honest, I'm still shocked that people are actively choosing
to watch VTubers that don't have a big old pair of jugs cuz that's
the only reason why I watch them to begin with. Anyways, it's
I feel like he saw the Shamu clip. I feel like he did. And he's
got to be like, I only love VTubers with huge, guys. I would
never partake in any lolly adjacent things at all. I I only like
the ones with huge Yeah. And then we go over to this guy and
it's like, wait, what did you want to do with this like 9-year-old
lollies? Dude, I feel like if Palon were to visit me, I feel
like we'd just be best friends,
you know? And I bet she would taste delicious.
Imagine how Pon's feet would taste when she's 18. Probably like
cinnamon and honey. Is Cleop.
What was the next one? The next one is not doesn't quite quite
Yeah, it doesn't hit quite hard, but it's still No. Is she terrible?
No. Okay. She's awesome. I love her and she definitely deserves
to be a fivestar. We're going to bust this open right now. Sucross,
you can suck them in. Clay, jerk them off. You go in Jang Lang.
She is generally considered to be around 7 to 10 years old in
terms of her mental and physical appearance. That one. K, you're
playing a video game. Okay. Maybe that's compelling to people.
I don't know. That one I'm like, whatever.
He was playing he was playing his lolly game. Okay. Oh, Jesus.
Okay. All right. I don't know. There's there's a lot of good
in that techone video. I was just going to check out this uh
I just want to see talking about his exes and he was like
what was his rundown of them that his ex Elaine was the best
one but she
him harder than he her and that was I don't know why we got those
details and then there was some girlfriend that he had that she
sucked but she had big where is that yeah I'm trying to think
of like what was said Just find Elaine or high school. High school.
These just these two friends in high school thing.
Oh. Oh, right here. Boom. Elena. Elena was a great girlfriend.
That was way back in the day. That was back in college. She was
great. Just generally she was way too aggressive.
She She wasing me way harder than I her and I was like, damn,
I can't handle this. I never really liked until like, you know,
31 this year. Yet they call me a fest. Yeah. Jesus. It is insane,
man. The truth doesn't matter anymore. It doesn't. It's like
the court. Truth doesn't matter. Only matters what you can prove.
And on the internet, the truth doesn't matter. It only matters
we can get people to believe. I think I think it's sickening
how little people go, "hm, let me Google that." They go,
yeah, we don't really know what that means for sure." Okay. We
don't Was she throwing it back too hard or was she [__]
Uh, how can I I can't make jokes without it being about And it's
so up. Maybe that's the only thing he gets off to now me. I said
this and
I really want Hassan to eat my so I'll go ahead and believe this.
Well, Denim said this and Oh, she's at least a six out of 10.
I've never seen a woman before. So, I'm Yeah, I'm going to watch
her forever. I believe what she says. Good lord, that whole Hassan
click is disgusting. Like we are we are in the day and age
where
we have actual
super villains.
When you see like this, I do actually kind of start liking them.
This is the problem, right? This is the constant problem I'm
stuck. I'm constantly having to try and make myself not like
any of these people because like they're not good or anything,
but they annoy the out tone and no and Ethan. And so I'm kind
of drawn to like
They're kind of funny sometimes, especially when they're saying
stuff about Tech's dad being around or No being. It's like it's
it's just a very easy win. Dude, we uh What is Cherry
Is there a I have no idea. Is there a clip of Denim's actually
calling him a or does he just make that up? Cuz Cherry's pretty
convinced and all I can see you later, Kyoko. Cherry's pretty
convinced and I now that I think about it. Um, she's she said
she believes the allegations and that he's a pest. She's called
a I don't know if she's ever said. Yeah. Believes the allegations
that somebody else was saying something. Go ahead. And if you
pull up the clip, uh, the chatter that she's replying to, she
does the Hassan thing where she pulls up the chat log and so
you can see exactly who she's responding to. Even in that chat
log, he's not saying you call him a So in that entire clip, not
on the screen. and not in the words that she says. Does she Does
it imply that like um rape him being called a rape is something
that's um being tackled there? It would Yeah, I mean it would
be awesome if she called him a rapist. Anyway, I just it to me
it shows that he knows that he's like um intentionally characterizing
her some way when every time he pulls it up he gives people
I think comes off like a guilty conscience like he's like knows
he's done something. That's just an opinion just to be clear.
Yeah. Uh, I just kind of listen, I believe he's a piece of
I just don't find it that strange to believe that he would uh
also slip some other stuff in there. Okay. But nobody would accuse
him of rape. As he's pointed out, he can't even he can't even
like get it up for the thought of like penetrating a woman. Nobody's
accusing him of like really well oral. I guess I don't know.
I don't know what the I don't know if you call that assault or
to be honest. I actually feel so uncomfortable
at the the section where he brings up like the him being three
now that I realize you're he's kind of like implying that's when
he was No, I don't think he's implying that. No, I don't think
I think he said he just said I gained empathy three. What? Okay,
hold on. No, come on. We got a third We got a third party here
now cuz I I that's immediately what I thought and I just Yeah.
after the invoking Reckful and like he's never even met Reckful,
but this is like somebody he looks up to. Oh, he talks about
like what losers I think about it every day. I think about how
hard you guys have it. I think about how difficult the world
is. I think about how much
I'm not going to lie up. I'm a pretty emotional guy. I'm not
going to lie. And I know it I know it's not good to be an emotional
guy in the content creator space, but I developed empathy at
3 years old. What does that mean?
I don't I don't know. I I guess he just thinks he's like best
person ever. He's just like, "Oh, I learned empathy so young."
I just feel for everyone, man. Uh maybe. I feel like that implies
something happened at 3 years old. It just can't be the thing.
It can't be the thing. It's got to be something else. I feel
like he's thinking of an event that he remembers from when he
was three. But it can't be the thing. It can't
It's got to be something else. Timeline. That wasn't when he
was three. I don't Yeah. It was like when he was seven or 10
or something. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, he's just like
a dramatic because who the knows that they had empathy at 3 years
old? I don't know what that means.
Wounded at 30. Maybe that's what he's doing. That's an opinion.
Of course, guys. That's an opinion. Okay. I actually don't know.
Those might all be facts. Um, we we're doing commentating and
punditry here. I also think it's actually super lucrative to
be an emotional guy like this on the internet. to be so emotionally
upset at somebody accusing you or your dad of being like Yeah,
you kind of get the incel internet's like sympathy
instantly. How is it not lucrative? You brag about making $400,000
a month. I I do love that he constantly complains about cancel
culture and how it's come for him and he has like doubled his
income or tripled his income in the past like six months
and following. Yeah. Yeah. It's a little baffling.
little bit baffling. There's such a massive like there's a complex
right now of these streamers. Oh, streamers and like uh video
essaists, right? Rev says Du Sensitive Society. He shouts out
some YouTubers here at the end if uh I'll throw these guys out
here real quick. Thank god. No, wrong window. Thank god. Wait,
wait, what? What? What? What? What? He's just mid maxing boogie
in WWE. I don't know what that is. He didn't want to be a WWE
wrestler. Oh, he did. Rev hates techone. That's shocking.
Rev and Asmin Gold are still pretty aligned, right? You're telling
me there's a Rev Teone rift?
Really? That's surprising. Yeah, it was a Techone kind of day
today. Hold on. I'm I'm going to I'm glad we have people like
Sensitive Society and more Pegasus.
piece of calling me a Genchin player. few. I just feel like that's
three YouTubers that it's like, "Oh, I can see why exactly why
you'd like those three YouTubers." I get it. I get it. Tect tried
to cancel another Genchin creator for the same tier he did with
tier list he did with lollies.
Wait, which Genchin creator is that? Cuz I do think uh that is
kind of funny. Can we have a chatter come in and tell us that
like last year?
Yeah, Yas came in. Yas hates Techone. Yeah, that's where the
potato girl came
Yeah. Yeah. Yas hates Techone,
oddly
enough. Um, what was it? Yeah, she just was talking about the
Genchin stuff, but I wonder who the Genchin creator was.
Plays with every other Genchin creator. It's kind of strange.
Yeah, I cuz I know he canceled some other Genchin creators. He
mentions them in this as well. Yeah, I think she like outlined
his previous
um in with that community about how he's like a crybully. Yeah,
he is a total
God, he's just the worst. Okay, I want to watch the sensitive
sensitive society video on denims because I think
I just like watching it. I find it very funny to watch.
Maybe I just find it very funny to watch how much people are
farming just hating these women. Like how much just how much
money. Okay, they should honestly
Ethan Klein should be filling up that GoFundMe just in general
for denims. Everybody has made so much money off of uh off of
just farming denims and Caseyron and Froggen. Like, how do they
have no Oh, Atu is one of the people he canceled. How do they
have no appreciation for the person who's giving them all of
their content? Like, zero. Like, literally, what would you get
up and talk about if this if denims didn't exist? I don't even
know. I have no idea. Male content creators. They don't know
how